une production du studio sf
bio venus au sans filtre les bobcats ont
parlé ce qu'on veut avec nos invités
date si tu te plantes avec moi ph
quentin 1 et cette semaine à new me nous
unit aux perches voulait avoir le
privilège de présenter parce qu'il a
beaucoup alors
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas et
exister comme ça par un invité qu'on
recevait ont reçu un mathieu blanchard
qui est un ultra marathonien à élite en
fait qu' un niveau international qui
arrivait en trop troisième aux autres
autour du mont blanc la plus
prestigieuse course ultra au monde donc
et on a parlé a évidemment de son
parcours en tant que le pro marathonien
on a parlé du film que fait qu'ils
s'appellent confiné qui est disponible
sur vimeo en ce moment si vous voulez
vous en vous le regardez en fait il ya
fait 650 km dans le parc de la gaspésie
en sept jours donc c'est le plus rapide
à l avoir fait un film magnifique on est
devant un film qui peut s'expliquer un
thriller comme dom l'écouté qui puis
ensuite on a parlé évidemment de
l'impact du sport dans nos vies on a
parlé de comment ça pouvait nous grande
et on a parlé
du dépassement de soi de la tête des
limites de repousser la limite de
l'homme
ce serait vraiment fascinant belle leçon
de résilience de travail dépassement de
soi moi j'en ressors de 4 complètement
craqué j'ai une goutte de d'atteinte oui
le docteur murray dépenses éliminés
j'espère que sa part surtout ses pieds
ce à quoi ça at-il podcast est complexe
parce qu'ici les coûts complets barça
tric trac il ya vraiment du monster
qu'on a discuté un peu plus loin la
première paquet et honnêtement donne
tort souvent des réflexions extrêmement
pertinentes et intéressantes mais je
pense que par le podcast sortie
proment la réflexion la plus pertinente
que deux sorties depuis de violon
d'enfance fait que essayer de leur père
dinis
avant d'aller fêter podcast je vais vous
présenter un projet qui me chagrine
dureau s'annonce pour moi cette semaine
je lance ma nouvelle compagnie du picard
avec mon nouveau produit le premier pic
à endurance c'est quoi le camp durant
c'est un carburant pour les sports
d'endurance quimper le sport d'endurance
et tous les sports de 45 minutes en
montant donc course à pied vélo natation
escalade boxe et cetera et cetera
c'est quoi exactement c'est une poudre
tout-en-un que vous mettez dans votre
bouteille d'eau dans 650 millions
d'euros en fait un scoop à chaque 45 60
minutes d'entraînement là dedans de 25 g
de glucides donc votre énergie dont vous
avez besoin pour l'activité dans les 25
g de glucides en a seize grammes de
dextrine cycliques d'étain glucides à
absorption rapide et à vidange gastrique
rapide donc ça reste pas dans l'estomac
puis ça vous donne pas mal au coeur à
force d'en prendre en continu on a 300
mg de sodium qui vient de sel rose de
malaya pour la rétention d'eau pour
éviter de perdre toute votre or quand
vous jouez on a des électrolytes en
quantité considérable donc accepte la
baston différence des prix des produits
d'électronique il ya un mais deux jeux
pour différents noms que ça fait zéro
différence donc on a ceux là dedans on a
en plus un ajout de taurine de vitamine
b12 vitamine c pour garder là
l'endurance musculaire en fait tout au
long de l'activité dont un produit
vraiment tout en optimisant un produit
premium pour ceux qui prennent leur
entraînement au sérieux ou ce qu'ils
veulent au moins
carburer à la hauteur de leurs efforts
on a deux savoir on n'a pas le show
fruits on a citron l'hymne de ses
possibles ah ouais c'est ça qui est lé
bon devant moins ceux qui sont sur
youtube donc pas une chaufferie citron
on aime aller sur le site du pic à point
ca pour plus d'informations et pour vous
procurer ces produits là je vous
garantis mois avant d'élever des formes
en fait en les faisant j'ai testé tous
les produits sur le marché ou presque
tout du moins si honnêtement
on est arrivé à la formule idéale pour
vrai c'est la meilleure chose que j'ai
testé pis ça fait longtemps je fais du
sport ça va faire plus de 25 ans que je
fais du sport à un niveau somme toute
est levée c'est la meilleure chose que
j'ai testé pour pendant l'entraînement
maximisez vos performances dans plus de
maximiser la récupération
essayé sur qui vous allez tout de suite
comprendre qu'est ce que je veux dire
une pique à point c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
et d'orientation et puis ça me faisait
rire parce que c'est hyper ingrat là tu
parles pas c'est qui qui parlait de
tutelle à la piscine avec une fille qui
n'agissent avait pas de bon sens comme
elle te défoncer away et moi je nage
avec jeune âgé parce que j'essaie de
faire un ironman pour m'amuser il ya
dernière et puis il fallait que
m'entraîner à nager tu vois que j'allais
nager que mon amie marianne hogan qui
est une nageuse depuis toujours
l'athlète qui est entre la tête trop
puis jusqu'au je comprenais pas ça me
rendait fou quoi la vie en une minute
chez elle à l'horizon la disparue et je
m'arrache et puis quand même costaud si
j'ai fait du sport de du haut du corps
avant et puis j'aime solide support à
kouadio son discours à kotick mais juste
jeune âge et puis je comprends pas
comment un trois coups de main elle peut
aller aussi l'épicerie ces pays bouge
même pas je comprends pas la natation
c'est vraiment technique puis j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme quelque
chose que c'était le pas développé
jeunes c'est notre style up cette espèce
de compréhension le de l'eau c'est
difficile à comprendre plus tard comme
apprendre une langue qu'ils n'ont cessé
si c'est le leur je pensais le sport
techniquement le plus le plomb j'étais
rendu à me dire c'est pas possible leur
peau est différente à ces gens là bas
parce qu'ils ont des faux de comme les
requins là qui glisse dans l'eau je ne
peux pas y croire quand un coup de bras
ils font de mètres d'un coup comme ça et
puis moi je fais 50 cm
ouais je les fais j'ai fait c'était en
2020 la lame et qu'avait de l'année
coville exacte et puis en préparation de
mon gros grosse aventure gr là comme
j'avais prévu de mon but c'était pas un
kilométrage hebdomadaire pour faire ses
650 km mais c'était plus une durée
abdomen durée quotidienne de courir
entre 15 et 20 heures par jour mais pour
courir 15 à 20 heures par jour je ne
pouvais pas m'entraîner à courir 15 ans
il fallait que je diversifie les sports
et c'est là que j'ai commencé à faire du
vélo de la natation et au début j'avais
pas là l'objectif iron man mais j'allais
nager tous les matins à 6 heures du
matin à dans le saint laurent là et puis
c'était horrible parce qu'en plus je
pouvais pas écouter le podcast
tourner en rond entre des bouées là
alors c'est cool parce que je passais la
digue et puis le courant qui me ramener
jusqu'à ce que je me dise mes méthodes
l'objectif de 2 de faire un triathlon
quoi et puis ça a tout changé le
lendemain quand je retournais que
m'étais dit ok je vais aller faire la
grande demande de mont tremblant en fait
parce qu'il était annulé mais j'ai pris
plaisir à aller nager à faire des heures
et des heures de vélo quoi et donc je
suis allée faire la grande demande de
tremblant le croit le jour qui était
prévu mais annulée puis on a fait le
parcours officiel que c'était plusieurs
oui moi moi et ma copine
marianne marianne ces fous pareils le
27 qui change quand un objectif le mot
moi je l' ai vécu beaucoup quand je
mangeais l'été pour être capable de
motiver souvent quand je nageais dans
l'entraînement je me voyais faire ma
performance tout le temps tous quelque
chose tu fais maintenant quand tu vas
courir quand tu job quand tu vas faire
mettons des gros truands perçant sur 100
% surtout sur les gros objectif the late
déjà là je pense à cette ut mb 2022 où
je vais retourner là mes entraînements
actuellement je fais déjà de la
visualisation je suis en train de courir
sur le mont royal et puis je me chaque
montée où je souffre un peu où je me
couche je me dis là ce qui est en train
de développer au niveau de tes petites
jambes des mitochondries de ton moteur
mais ça va te servira pas souffrir
pendant ses montées à lutter mais donc
oui après mon champ entièrement d'accord
que si on n'a pas un objectif en tête
c'est dur de s'entraîner mais par contre
c'est pas pour moi ce n'est pas obligé
que ce soit un objectif de compétition
de course ça peut être un pourquoi on
est totalement différent là mais aucune
raison en quoi une raison de sortir
parce qu'on s'est pas ce n'est pas
confortable est d'aller d'aller d'aller
faire de l'endurance pour personne mais
dès qu'il ya un objectif 20 est tout de
suite plus facile qu est ce une raison
[Musique]
ça peut être ça peut être la raison la
plus banale de tout moi c'est celle qui
a fait que j'ai commencé à courir c'est
de perdre du poids et de rester en forme
c'est très banal mais ça peut être une
raison valable il ya pas de ya pas de
jugement sur sa lame et c'est la raison
la plus classique rester à santé et
perdre du poids donc ça ça peut être
pourquoi fort au début après il y en a
beaucoup au 6è ça peut être deux le lien
social est très fort et très fort dans
en tout cas dans mon sport dans la
course à pied là il ya beaucoup de
coureurs autour de moi qui se retrouvent
l'effet de groupe le mardi soir le
mercredi soir dans des social run groupe
pour aller courir parce qu'ils vont
jaser pendant une heure et utiliser le
prétexte de la course pour les se
rencontrent et puis c'est tout et c'est
gagnant gagnant parce que tu fais ta
dans l'activité physique tu tu nourris
au site ont besoin de lien social en
même temps donc ça ça peut être un
pourquoi très fort aussi mais il ya
aussi prendre une revanche sur la vie
par rapport à une maladie il ya aussi
s'engager dans un projet on a beaucoup
qui font ça aussi à les dépasser sur un
objectif un peu dingue pour faire une
levée fonds pour avoir un peu une esprit
philanthropique parce que deux proches
de loin ils ont été touchés par
quelqu'un qui a qui a pas eu la même
chance que dans la vie et puis il y en a
énormément ce qui est important je le
fais chaque année c'est un général c'est
en décembre ça dans cette période
hivernale où on un peu plus relax et
puis on est moins stressé par les
objectifs c'est justement de faire un
bilan sur l'année il ya quelques outils
sont en années précédentes sur voilà
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour redéfinir
temps pourquoi chaque année parce que
c'est ce qui va vraiment motivé a
atteint en faire beaucoup plus que ce
qu'il faut faire si tu veux prendre et
donc moi je fais cet exercice là
vraiment un papier stylo qui est
2021 c'était quoi mes plus grosses
émotions je tire une ligne au milieu tu
vois les émotions méga positive en eau
les émotions méga négativement pas il
faut les écrire les négative aussi parce
qu'elles peuvent avoir un impact sur ton
pourquoi tu tires la ligne de l'astre
l'année puis c'est pas obligé que ça
soit les trucs incroyables c'est pas
forcément la ligne d'arrivée d'un muté
mb ou d'une course folle ça peut être un
truc très très banal qui s'est passé un
repas de famille peu importe puis avec
tout ça tu finis par trouver mais
qu'est-ce qui t'anime là et tu es tu
redéfinit at&t pourquoi l'année d'après
qui vont t'aider à te lever tout le
monde pourquoi soit fort quand même
parce que les sacrifices puis
l'engagement que sa demande est
tellement immense qu'il faut que là
pourquoi faut que la raison asseoir
forte soit forte pour toi ouais c'est ça
pour toi il peut y en avoir plusieurs
est d'ailleurs de pourquoi aussi un pack
un peu n'avoir rien à voir plusieurs
mais pour toi y en a pour qui ça peut
être très banal comme raison mais si toi
tu y crois mais tu t'en fous du jugement
là et puis c'est ce qui va te permettre
de vraiment de te motive et puis toi ton
bilan 2021 il ya eu évidemment d émotion
extrêmement positif j'imagine avec
toutes les succès puis pas mal de
breaking à la carrière d'athlète
professionnel mais quels sont les
émotions plus négative que te réussi à
cibler puis surtout nous parle
évidemment puis depuis quand est-ce que
tu les transferts dans ta
dans ton côté objectifs ou ta ligne
directrice dans l'année qui s'en vient
pour essayer de pas les reproduire ou du
moins essayer d'apprendre d'eux
c'est une très bonne question et puis en
général c'est des cds suivie un peu plus
intime mais c'est vrai que ce que tu
veux nous moi
mais
tcc depuis deux ans avec ses périodes de
pandémie là c'est pour un athlète de
haut niveau c'est compliqué bon moi je
suis quelqu'un qui est toujours très
optimiste et qui réussit à transformer
des situations très négative en
situation assez positives mais on essaye
de sourire mais le backstage est quand
même compliquée l'a48 je t'engage sur
des courses et de fumer tue mais corey
hamel d'un an dans tant de dévouement
pour ton sport tu t'es pas tout seul est
engagé avec toi tu as tes proches de la
compagnie tetezamita familles doivent te
soutenir là dedans et le mans les
adresser un très lointain vive voix là
et puis quand karl déroulé ne se passe
pas comme prévu à cause d'une situation
externe mais c'est sûr que c'est
difficile alors c'est sûr quand
tu es de 2000 2019-2020 ça a été des
années très difficiles pour moi 2010 9
c'est l'année où ça a été la grosse
transition un petit peu où j'ai quitté
la vie de bureau classique la voilà mais
je me suis blessé et donc ça a été une
année en demi-teinte 2020 kovy des puits
et et j'avais quitté pour justement
réorganiser montant pour pour faire des
choses grandes banques puissent abri
faut être patient mais deux ans ans qui
se passe rien bond 2020 j'ai quand même
réussi à
transformer quelque chose à travers
l'aventuré ça ya eu des mois par les
choses mais voilà j'attendais vraiment
2021 au tournant et puis après bon
l'année
voilà l'année dès le départ tu vois je
me suis vraiment fait un gros gros gros
entraînement hivernal comme jamais puis
première course de l'année j'arrive aux
canaries et puis je fais des erreurs de
débutants tu vois gtgc ça aussi des fois
quand à cannes times est certaine
notoriété dans le sport tu vas te faire
inviter facilement dans des bosquets
tout et ça peut être à double tranchant
dreux voiles en profiter et ce fameux
petit déjeuner
brunch fins et illimitée le matin qui
est invite tous mangé faut éviter de le
faire le jour de la course bon grand
verre de lait la dalle est ouvert voilà
et puis j'ai toujours eu le ventre assez
costaud et puis je faisais trop
confiance puis voilà rester plus gros
échecs tu vois la course n'a pas été à
mes ambitions que je me suis dit doit
finalement c'est la troisième année que
ça ça recommence depuis depuis en fait
depuis que j'ai quitté ma main tu as vu
de murs horrible bureau et fonctionne
pas là et ça donne raison à tous c'est
ce qui m'énerve ce que ça donnait raison
à toutes les personnes qui
m'encourageait pas dans cette démarche
bon c'est pas c'est pas en territoire
nord américain que ça se passait mais
c'était le but du côté de l'europe mais
ça commence à être pesant tu vois et
donc il ya eu ça après je suis retourné
encore en polynésie chaque année je vais
là-bas parce que c'est un territoire qui
est très fort d'un point de vue
énergétique là et je repars de l'abattre
et craque et voilà et encore une fois je
suis allé là j regagner ma course ça m'a
remis en confiance sur parti et non
c'est ça 2000-2002 1021 allez les
les émotions les plus les plus négatives
cc c'est surtout
le manque de confiance le manque d'
estime de soi le doute qui était très
présente très pesant qui m'a beaucoup
pesé puis je vois là j'ai beaucoup pensé
à ça comment j'ai réussi à passer à
travers comment j'ai réussi à bâtir ma
confiance et aujourd'hui grâce aux
expériences qui sont arrivés après
notamment l'utmb qui a été qui a été un
tournant de ma carrière
j'ai voilà j'ai pris confiance j'ai bâti
mon estime de soi et puis voilà c'est ça
a été les moments marquants et c'est
aujourd'hui voilà mon mais pourquoi pour
2022 repartent avec mathieu beaucoup
plus solide dans sa tête et la confiance
confiance en lui donc c'est sûr que ça
soulage beaucoup dans dans ce qui va
devenir quoi moi j'étais jeter découvert
ou ultra trail du mont blanc donc l'utmb
qu'on parle plutôt pour ceux qui nous
écoutent parce que on n'est pas un
podcast spécifié que le trottoir il le
fait qu'ils emmenaient dans nos
auditeurs qui savent pas qu'on parle moi
c'est là que j'étais me rencontrer pour
la première fois de façon unie
directionnelle ou est ce que j'écoutais
le broadcast de chez nous dans le fond
je regardais la la fin de la course où
le dernier les derniers les dernières
dizaines de kilomètres plus loin mathieu
blanchard france qui est ce mon île
comme ça va bien ça l'air de bien aller
n'est négatif iran manif des passes des
gens prêts à mener sur le sur le
broadcast mentionne que tu habites au
canada plus je fais un français qui
habite au canada et doit pas but à
calgary le 18 doit habiter à montréal
fait finalement j'appelle mes potes qui
est ultra puis qui connaît sa pizza
aussi viennent mauriange j'y crois
morial pilar un lieu qui habitant morial
qui arrivent troisièmes à le traduire du
mont blanc soit pour le reste de ta vie
ça va être probablement un peu importe
qu est ce qui arrive après ça va être le
moment pivot j'imagine dans ta carrière
d'athlète parce que c'est pour ceux qui
nous écoutent si le super bowl des ultra
trail c'est la plus grosse course au
monde qu'il arrivait troisième avec un
temps qui aurait gagné à d'autres années
c'est assez incroyable puis je tendais
sur le podcast de jean philippe wauthier
ou est ce que tu disais que
tu avais jusque là ça rejoint un petit
peu ce que tu dis le syndrome de
l'imposteur quand arrivait sur ces
courses l'envisager j'ai pas d'affaires
est à côté de de françois de ginger eli
lilly les légendes du sport qu'est ce
que je fais ici j'imagine que ça te
vraiment conforté dans le fait que ta
vie ta place le de faire cette course le
nom est vraiment 100% ça a été ça a été
le tournant et puis tj
j'ai pas de gêne à le dire tu es
vraiment ce syndrome de l'imposteur la
cct tu verras tu tu remarqueras sur les
sur les courses un petit peu de
catégorie b et c où il ya quelques bons
coureurs mais pas non plus toute la
crème de la crème je vais pas jane hamed
sow en france y voit mais
g foulée mais ces voix là mais ces
grosses courses là j'ai toujours eu tu
es tu vois même car je me revois sur les
images là j'ai toujours en seconde ligne
la tête un peu baissé les yeux par terre
parce que je supporte pas ce regard de
de c2c de ces légendes qui m'inspire
énormément et qui je voue je vois
j'arrive à lire tjs et cette sensibilité
là pour lire dans leurs yeux qu'ils ils
se disent ok toi je te connais toi je te
connais ton ami et toi t'es qui toi
qu'est ce tu fous là naquit alors j'ai
la chance d'être là parce que j'ai couru
assez vite dans d'autres courses pour
avoir des points qui fait que j'ai un
dossard pour cet endroit là à ce moment
là mais personne ne connaît donc c'est
très très pesant est sacrée ça crée une
anxiété un stress qui te tires de
l'énergie qui te fait mal au ventre
avant même d'avoir commencé dont on n'a
pas besoin pour ce genre de des preuves
et
oui ben l'histoire tu l'as tu l'a évoqué
la suite terminé sur le podium de cette
course tout de suite c'est là où
et puis même ce qui est drôle quand je
suis arrivé je me souviens le
je parle avec le manager de salomon et
judy comme d'habitude tu vois j'avais
encore un petit peu cette mon petit
syndrome et puis c'est ce que j'avais
fait dans un autre tmb où je m'étais
bien pas placer la première fois j'ai
dit oui je suis arrivé en troisième
position mais c'est parce que les
légendes ont abandonné où ils ont eu des
problèmes tu vois puis c'est là où ça a
été vraiment très fort ce qu'il m'a dit
il m'a dit mais non matt ton temps nous
regarde ton temps là 21 heures et des
poussières sur une autre édition c'est
un temps qui permet de gagner et et là
c'est vrai que c'est à sa sa mesure
qu'on subisse a permis d' un petit peu
cheminée et puis aujourd'hui je suis
beaucoup plus en confiance et puis je
sens que lorsque je serai sur une ligne
de départ tu vois tu parlais de 10 mois
mais on s'y retrouve en afrique du sud
on s'est remis à un mois je suis arrivé
me connaissent et on s'est parlé on a
reparlé de l'utmb il s'est rappelé du
moment où je les doubler après courait
après après cours mayer et puis tu vois
ça change tout et là il est ressenti je
suis parti aux côtés de djimla
l'afrique du sud et j'avais plus cette
sensation donc
confiance estime de soi dans le monde du
sport comme dans
tout hyper important et c'est hyper
important et c'est très difficile de
trouver la manière de 2,2 de construire
ça et puis ben moi le déclic ça a été de
faire un podium sur une course alors je
sais pas si c'est la bonne manière ou
pas mais en tout cas ça peut être aussi
banal que ça 2 2 juste faire une
position où un temps qui va tout changer
tu as senti aussi qu'il le regard que
les autres portent sur toi tu sais de
cette royauté l'ossétie meilleur le de
désespoir le cas maintenant 200 tic tac
toe comme rentrer dans le club joue à
100% parce que le thé le lendemain il ya
eu il ya eu les podiums puis nous
on était les dix premiers à monter pour
voilà faire la cérémonie et on avait une
tente un petit peu caché puis sont tous
venus me voir en me disant m at&t bravo
pour ce que tu as fait on s'attendait
pas à autant cider très très beau très
impressionnant très inspirant bla bla
bla depuis quand c'est un françois deyn
qui viennent devant a qui disent hâtif
et oies ok j'y suis et les semaines qui
ont suivi tu vois sur les réseaux
sociaux des stars m'ont écrit dieu de
lui de ce moment de la d'ultra trail et
enfin des sardes de l'ultra trail
pour me dire ben ouais bravo super ce
que tu as fait très inspirant hâte de me
confronter à toi en compétition en 2022
quoi donc c'est
le droit turc du mont blanc
c'est absolument in stream ag
j'ai essayé la dépense et de faire le 80
km2 d'ultras de bromont puis puis j'ai
abandonné à 56 km lorsque j'étais
j'étais complètement sauté le toiture du
mont-blanc ses 160 170 kg 172 le
parcours officiel exactement avec le
tchad qui le mettrait alors on calcule
plus avec combien dénivelé positif 10000
c'est absolument débile
cette grandeur le deux choses pis comme
commun à l'intérieur de cette course
laisse que tu gères parce que au-delà de
tout ce qui est technique mais ton
lembeye l'entraînement évidemment la
nutrition ces choses là qui doivent pas
être prises en compte qui compte pour
beaucoup dans dans une performance comme
ça mais c'est tellement long que tu dois
avoir des hauts et des bas vraiment
vraiment marqué pendant la course des
voix des bosses ça doit pouvoir durer 20
kg le 30 kg de cinq erreurs de darna
dire que ç'a fini puis au final tu t'en
sors de ce comment tu gères ce dans une
course de cette amplitude le parce que
c'est sur carnot à moi je me trompe non
non c'est sûr et puis si tu as fait
bromont et que tu abandonné je pense que
tu as dû passer par par un basque
effectué abandonné oui
c'est ça peut-être qu'avec l'expérience
si tu continues à explorer
le tht peut-être que la prochaine fois
lorsque tu va ressentir exactement ce
même d'armes que tu as eue à bromont
comme tu l'auras déjà une première fois
tu auras déjà une marque d'un ton en toi
dans ton cerveau dans notre sensation de
douleur dans ce que tu as vécu qui sera
déjà un vécu donc une potentielle
accoutumance et donc avec le temps et
l'expérience d'un rapport à la douleur
physique et mental tu es énergétique va
évoluer ou ça va devenir sur une échelle
de 5 sur 10 1 810 douloureux de quelques
années va devenir un 3 sur 10 tu vois et
sait c'est que pour moi
grand dieu aujourd'hui dans des sociétés
tellement
protégés avec beaucoup d'hygiène autour
de nous qui fait que quand on est enfant
on ne tombe pas en ce cas se passer la
gueule par terre et puis on finit par
voilà découvrir des vraies douleurs un
peu quand on se met dans des sports
comme ça assez tard dans la vie quand on
se pousse et puis on n'est pas on sait
pas accoutumés à ça dans notre jeunesse
mais en tout cas moi c'est mon
expérience aujourd'hui là et puis c'est
mon expérience là c'est pas forcément
validées scientifiquement ce que je vais
dire mais j'ai l'impression que mon
rapport à la douleur évolué avec le nord
donc c'est ça pour répondre à ta
question lorsque je vais être dans un
cas on est dans une course une douleur y
a que la blessure qui va m'arrêter au
final une vraie blessure c'est à dire
une jambe et il a je m'arrêter mais si
c'est une crampe eu une tension dans un
muscle ma tête qui veut plus une envie
de vomir c'est pas suffisant pour me
faire arrêter et avec l'expérience j'ai
appris que que voilà c'est la logique
voudrait que ce soit une courbe qui
partent d'un certain niveau d'énergie
est peu de douleur de la ligne de départ
jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée ça va être
juste au corps et descendantes descendre
dans des sens descendant jusqu'aux
enfers mais alors en fait c'est pas du
tout c'est pas du tout ça c'est hyper
magique et puis c'est incompréhensible
pour moi ça va être plutôt une sinusoïde
tu comprends pas pourquoi tout d'un coup
à la huitième heure de la 8e à la 10e
heures ça va pas du tout envie de vomir
tu as mal partout et tout d'un coup à la
douzième heure pas ce qui se passe ça va
bien tu as plus aucune douleur tu as un
niveau d'énergie de dengue et tout épicé
c'est ça donc ça tu la prend avec le
temps que cette courbe allait pas
descendre c'est plutôt une sinusoïde qui
peut revenir et donc tu sais quand dans
un dogme qui va toujours y avoir en à
peu près toujours toujours toujours
toujours à moins que ce soit une
blessure mais sinon ça va toujours en
avoir un donc ça quand tu le sais que
dans l'expérience l'accoutumance à la
douleur plus tu sais que tu vas voir en
ap après ben tu dis c'est cool là c'est
le moment où je vis ma douleur si tu
trouves tu trouve aussi après des
démarches prépare avant d'aider des bals
des webphones positive tu vois des
raisons je fais mais pourquoi aussi pour
chaque course pourquoi je vais à cette
course qui lie à la nana est donc un ça
va pas je me nourris de ces de c2c de
cebal positif que je m'envoie là et
et puis un truc est très puissant je me
dis tu es moi la douleur ça intensifier
un petit peu mais je me sens encore plus
vivant peut paraître un peu un peu
sadique mais je me dis
profitant de cette douleur parce qu'elle
va pas durer là tu te sens vraiment
vivant tu te sens sur terre là tu es là
tu es en train de rêver tu vois est
assez cool finalement de ressentir la
douleur je veux pas que ce soit quelque
chose de
l'interpréter comme quelque chose de
négatif
et au final je vous fais que ça et ça
passe très bien juste pour revenir sur
l'utmb tu tapes est aussi une question
qui disait comment gérer une course
aussi longue tout ça
l'utmb souvent on la décrit comme à
cesser les médias qui connaissent rien
là dedans on dirait c'est la course la
plus dure du monde du web l'annoncé pas
la course la plus dure du monde c'est la
course la plus si j'ai la plus
prestigieuse la plus ferme parce qu'il
ya tout le monde qui est là
voilà c'est comme tu dis le super bowl
mais ça passe forcément le match le plus
dur
mais alors la particularité qu'elle
l'utmb tu disais 10000 mètres de
dénivelé positif mais donc ça c'est la
description qu'on donne d'une course
mais quand c'est une quête une boue
quand c'est un cercle que tu reviens à
sa ligne de départ ça veut dire que tu
vas voir autant de dénivelé négatif et
qu'au final en cumul et avait 1000
mètres de dénivelé et le dénivelé
négatif est beaucoup plus la roma c'est
vraiment que le positif parce que
positif où il positif au final tu vas
marché un petit peu parce que ces
tropiques où tu vas être sur un rythme
plus comme tu sais que c'est un ultra tu
peux pas faire monter les tours notons
cardio donc moi la montée c'est le
moment où finalement je mange je chill
tout va bien mais la descente c'est là
qu'il faut envoyer la sauce parce que
c'est là que tu veux peut perdre
beaucoup de temps tu vois il c'est là
que des descentes des mines des 110 km
vertical là
tu fais ce qu'on appelle un mouvement
excentrique du muscle c'est à dire que
la contraction s'étire et c'est hyper
traumatisant pour les muscles donc ses
voiles à l'utm bien cette particularité
que le treuil sa sphère nature hockey et
au québec tu disais tout à l'heure que
moi j'ai grandi au québec en tant que
corps d'un réel etc grâce je pense à
cette culture cet état d'esprit et
surtout au terrain québécois
qu'aujourd'hui je me suis forgé dur dans
le dur dans le métal tu vois les peux
vous dire pour avoir fait le tour du
monde de toutes les courses possibles
imaginables
le bois québécois ja rule costaud irène
plus technique et la scène vers adeline
la boue les roches la halle à l'humidité
la chaleur les les virages cc66 tic on
sait claustrophobique la la forêt
québécoise et puis le seul endroit où
j'ai retrouvé des terrains aussi
difficile et qui train de danser la
jungle dans l'est dans les caraïbes tu
vois donc très très très costaud et dans
ces courses là il ya tellement
d'obstacles que tu en fait je voudrais
aller vite mais tu peux pas malgré ton
ton ta capacité cardiovasculaire tu été
freinée par des obstacles racines des
roches de la boue il ya quelque chose
donc c'est tout freiné l'utmb cette
particularité qu'il n'y a pas
d'obstacles voilà il ya du gros
dénivelés c'est en montagne mais c'est
des chemins qui sont empruntés par des
milliers des milliers de randonneurs
chaque année parce que le faire le tour
du mont blanc est une randonnée très
classique
dans ce monde là et donc les chemins 107
ap et sont assez propre mais c'est très
sournois parce qu'au final comme ta pâte
et comme tu as passé ces obstacles là
qui vont se ralentir c'est à toi de
décider dans ta tête de demain dans une
zone de confort où tu vas te freiner
sauf que il faut vraiment avoir une
connexion avec son corps une capacité à
choisir cette juste intensité pour
donner le meilleur de soi-même sur 20
heures de course que c'est hyper
sensible et c'est une course qui se
courent plus avec la tête qu'avec le
corps c'est un vrai casse-tête l'utmb il
faut être très intelligent avoir une
capacité de recul énorme pour cette
course là et on peut toujours se dire
que les coureurs sont débiles d'aller
courir et que ce c'est complètement bête
d'aller courir et qu'il faut juste
mettre une gerbe devant l'autre mais non
faut vraiment vraiment se poser et
réfléchir et comprendre le casse-tête du
truc et l'utm bien particulière est en
tout cas cette parce que sans obstacle
devient compliqué il faut savoir à quel
moment freiner accélérer
manger c'est une course qui est très
très très très très complexe et et moi
je veux y retourner cette année parce
que en 2022 je crois que j'ai compris un
petit peu quelques clés du casse tête et
qu'il n'avait pas compris non non non
non on n'avait pas compris et puis j'ai
remarqué aussi que beaucoup de
l'athlète élites qui sont bien meilleurs
que moi d'un point de vue capacité de
montagnards et de cardio vasculaires
mais qui n'ont pas compris le
fonctionnement du tmb qui fait que ça
donne beaucoup de chance à ceux qui ont
un peu plus casser le dos des secrets
c'est il ya quelque chose aussi dans
ceux
où sql les gens sont très très avares de
leur programme d'entraînement pied de
leur training sétois mettons depuis je
te suis sûr sur instagram sur des
réseaux sociaux depuis l' utmb justement
pas beaucoup d'idées de 2 c'est quoi ton
training lancé je sais pas c'est quoi tu
je sais pas mais tentons nombre de
kilomètres par semaine je ne sais pas
c'est quoi tu fais comme intervalle
versus comme dénivelé positif dans ta
semaine j'ai littéralement aucune aucune
vertu rapportent des fois quand mettons
à l'ultra cuir de cape town quant à
mener ton ton celle avec toi pendant la
reconnaissance du parcours mais tant
mieux c'est la limite de ce que je sais
c'est la même chose pas mal à travers
tous les athlètes puis mannequin quand
moi je mangeais un magie noire juge
qu'il ya 26 ans quand même un bon niveau
pee personne d autre le partager leurs
entraînements comme si ce t1 le secret
le mieux gardé lé c'est pourquoi tu
penses que c'est comme ça parce que j'ai
moi j'ai plus l'impression toute ma
carrière je me disais moi je m'en fous
de dieu sait quoi que tu es ma came dont
georges mais je m'en fous dire c'est
quoi je suis comme entraînement parce
que c'est pas l'entraînement c'est
comment tu fais l'entraînement et puis
moi c'est comme ça que je le voyais mais
on dirait qu'il ya comme quelque chose
de religion comme sont comme frileuse de
parler de qu'est ce qu'ils font il ya
énormément si c'est vraiment une très
bonne question il ya énormément de deux
raisons à ça je vais essayer de
t'exposer les principales
déjà le monde du sport enfin une cour
plus du trail de l'ultra-trail parce
qu'on rend dans la dimension à ces
extrêmes les programmes ou plus tu vas
loin au plus c'est du spécifique ou plus
le programme spécifique et
individualisée à chaque personne c'est à
dire que même pour une même course du
tmb mon programme d'entraînement va pas
du tout le même que notre athlète qui
valait sur l'utmb déjà ça c'est en
fonction de la personne et des capacités
de récupération de ton calendrier
hebdomadaire de cannes je peux
t'entraîner comment de ton milieu où tu
habites est-ce que tu habites à montréal
est ce que tu as de l'altitude de la
montagne etc donc c'est hyper complexe
dont déjà je crois que souvent les les
athlètes de haut niveau dans mon sport
en tout cas ne partage pas comme ça
aussi parce que je veux pas influencer
les autres à faire pareil que moi parce
que ce que je fais c'est ça devrait être
c'est pas du tout parce que je veux
cacher ce que je fais parce que en fait
je trouve que lui mais à ce vilain
défaut de de chercher la pilule miracle
ou une recette miracle qui fait que tu
va progresser en trois jours mathieu
blanchard fait ça c'est moi je fais
exactement
et pas du tout pas du tout il ya aucune
recette miracle est la seule recette me
drague c'est de s'entraîner bien
récupérer bien dormir bien manger et
bien pensée et donc je veux pas
influencer veux pas influencer d'autres
à faire ce que je fais parce que c'est
vrai que
les volumes ça évolue dans l'année mais
les volumes
sur du spécifique proche d'une course
comme l'utmb peuvent être assez dingue
sur une semaine et ce quelqu'un qui part
de rien
par l'effet contraire désir ou là ok
matif et 30 heures de course dans une
semaine il faut que je fasse ça s'est un
jour j'ai eu recours à lui tombé non pas
du tout tu peux t'entraîner différemment
tu peux faire que du vélo si tu veux et
puis un petit peu de course allié et
allez allez faire un 8ème et donc c'est
vraiment une notion de influence
positive tg ce travail là mais sur ce
travail mais je vais partager plutôt que
les les sorties les une belle sortie
devait faire avec des amis en fin de
semaine une belle mais l'entraînement
d'aujourd'hui je suis allé faire trois
fois cinq minutes de fractionner ap la
tour de mon quartier à montréal déjà je
trouve que les gens s'en foutent puis je
vais pas les influencer à le faire et
donc ça c'est la première chose est la
deuxième je te dirai aussi que c'est
c'est une question de temps en fait tout
simplement tg mois les réseaux sociaux
générer une relation avec les réseaux
sociaux qui est qui et que
je peux pas passer ma journée dessus
c'est déjà acté c'est que celle à 7 ans
atteint prend beaucoup du temps quand tu
auras des statistiques tout immigré
longtemps que l'iss temps que je passe
là dessus donc le peu de temps que je
vais donner aux réseaux sociaux je veux
que ça soit sur des des partages de
d'image de vidéos qu'ils soient plus
plus inspirantes pour le grand public
que pour l'expert en que l'expert en
ultra trail tu vois je veux partager de
belles images de la nature d'un tour
comme tu disais à ultra trail capteurs
mems ça faisait partie de mon
entraînement d'aller repérer la course
mais les belles images pour que la
personne qui va regarder ça qui est pas
forcément sportif se disent aussi stylée
moi aussi j'aimerais aller un peu dans
le monde arabe où chaque fois que je
voyais ton pas notification par
l'enquêté à capetown du cricket du sud
parce que c'était vraiment comme les
images paradisiaques noté des montagnes
le long de l'axé ça donc ça c'est mon
objectif de partager plus de voiles à
des dés de l'idée de la beauté de la
nature de la communauté étaient des
valeurs des valeurs qui gravitent autour
de mon sport qui ne sont pas techniques
à proprement parler mais des valeurs qui
s'extrait pas là tous milieux de vie
parce que je veux pas juste avoir des
geeks de de paye ses 2 v/m à kiki qui
s'intéressent à mon contenu donc voilà
c'est dans ma journée je m'entraîne
beaucoup là ça me prend beaucoup
d'énergie pense à mon entraînement
allait le faire tous les projets annexes
et puis peut-être un moment donné dans
la journée je vais avoir 30 minutes pour
penser à un poste à une story et puis là
je veux le faire voilà des belles images
plutôt que de regarder fractionné que
j'ai fait voilà donc c'est un peu ça et
je pense que c'est la même chose pour en
tout cas dans mon sport pour beaucoup
d'athlètes que je vois autour de moi
montre leur environnement
d'entraînement qui est souvent assez
assez beau comme paysage et puis je
crois que ça inspire beaucoup plus notre
communauté a
à aimer le milieu naturel à se sortir un
peu de la ville pour aller connecté à sa
queue dès que des histoires de pays ces
deux programmes d'entraînement par fait
recette magique qui n'existe finalement
pas c'est là c'est la beauté d'ultra
c'est vraiment la connexion avec la
nature on dirait puis dans le film
confiné moi c'est ce qui m'a frappé
c'est vraiment utile voir le québec de
cet oeil là de leur crime que moi je
n'ai jamais vu c'est juste des chefs de
deux drones à la gaspésie de toutes ses
beaux paysages l'hautil la forêt la
bonne vieille forêt boréale du québec je
trouve ça complètement magnifique puis
je veux qu'on parle absolument de
confiner parce que c'est sans l'ombre
d'un doute la chose la plus une scène
que j'ai que j'ai vu c'est 650 km sur
sept jours avec 30000 dénivelé positif
en espionnant affaire de fous puis je
veux je veux que tu m'expliques comment
tu décides de faire ce pour quoi
ça m'apparaît tellement surhumain comme
comme exploit que je veux savoir la
jeunesse de tout seul alors la genèse
est assez banal on s'attend toujours à
ce que je raconte des histoires
incroyables d'été je vais commencer à
courir la course à pied pour prendre un
peu de poids que voilà mais la lyonnaise
est assez banal finalement c'était en
2016 moi je suis arrivé au québec en
janvier 2014 ont fait deux ans que
j'étais là je commençais à courir un
petit peu mais de manière très
tranquille commence à courir en 2014
ouais c'est
l'information qui est quand même kim kim
fait capoter à chaque fois je ne savais
pas c'est tantôt en parler de déraison
mais je ne savais pas quand cette
descente et commençait donc ses grands
quand tu arrives au québec voilà qui
commence à courir pour chamand les
raisons communes distantes opi servant
de fil en aiguille se rendre compte que
tu aimes et sopi je voulais pousser ce
pif commence à voir la compétition plus
neutres exact petite parenthèse là
dessus donc 2014 atterri en janvier je
vais me passer deux ans à paris dans une
santé votre cas red bull pas terrible tu
vois pas ce que je fais trop stressé la
semaine dans ma vie donc je me détende
est comme ça à la fin de semaine il
était un plus qu'un robot voilà et mais
sam sam ça me ressemblait pas parce que
dans ma jeunesse j'ai grandi en campagne
et puis j'étais quelqu'un du plein air
puis je l'avais perdu dans cette région
parisienne et je voulais voilà on
retrouve un peu le match et que j'étais
avant donc voila c'était la raison de
banales qui a fait que j'ai commencé la
course mais pour moi c'était un sport de
transition et c'est devenu ma passion je
n'explique pas là c'est un coup de
foudre tu peux pas clairement clairement
tu devais avoir un talent vraiment de la
moyenne parce que parce que je commence
à courir cinq ans plus tard ou six ans
plus tard tepa 3e utmb le web seulement
mais bon là avec le recul que j'en ai
aujourd'hui la le le talent que j'ai ou
la particularité c'est d'avoir je pense
un mental très très solide plus qu'un
physique ou une génétique particulière
je vois pas ce que quand je vais c'est
je le vois quand j'allais courir avec
des amis toujours je suis le dernier à
avoir froid avoir chaud avoir mal
quelque part et quand et quintin
cabochons assez assez solide ça te
permet de te pousser dans des zones qui
sont pas forcément santé et je dirais
que ma relation à la course à pied au
début c'était catastrophique
c'était une relation amour haine parce
qu'en fait j'avais pas compris mais
j'étais blessée tout le temps ok je veux
tellement poussé c'est pour ça que j'ai
progressé aussi mais jamais quelque
chose que je recommanderais de faire
parce que ça a été une relation affreuse
jeu les trois premières années les
périostite l'ailé tfl les fans et les
douleurs au genou c'était l'enfer parce
que j'ai pas laissé le temps à mon corps
de s'adapter et la relation était
vraiment toxique et malsaine je trouve
et c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai eu la
chance de progresser vite mais j'ai eu
la chance aussi de pas m'arrêter quoi
parce que j'avais tellement mal que
j'aurais aimé voilà j'aurais dû
m'arrêter mais c'était une normalité
pour moi courir sens fall b ça fait mal
et puis les autres produits deux mois
fin mai ces croyances de la course à
pied c'est d'homme pas bon pour la santé
s'est fait mal au genou moi je me suis
dit ok c'est la normalité je vais le
faire jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve que c'est
pas du tout pas tout à fait ça mais
voilà c'est je pense que c'est plus la
tête qu'ils étaient solides que clash
l'éthique ta musique la grand mère corse
c'est un marathon la toute première
associable combien tu as fait un de
temps après ta première année j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé à courir sur le
mont royal en mars 2014 il fait le
marathon de montréal en septembre et je
les fais en 3h00
[Rires]
weah temps mais attendez après même pas
1 en course ouais mais quand même je te
dirais que de mars à septembre l'âge et
quand j'ai cliqué sur le bouton je
m'inscris au marathon de montréal ça a
fait un déclic dans ma tête et je suis
devenu chef devenu obsédé obsédé un taré
un geek enfin jeudi de la course des
livres je lisais tout je radote les
vidéos youtube et j'allais m'entraîner
comme comme un kenyan qui met les amis
cours une avicii one donc les tentes
mais ce chemin je me souvienne des
douleurs les tendons d'achille et où ils
me disaient mais un jeu passe à travers
je veux réussir mon marathon et et voilà
j'ai fait un programme qu'avec m'a
permis de faire ça la met
plus curieux par rapport à refaire en
arrière je referais tout différemment tu
vois je me laisserais du temps je
commencerai papara marathon mais moi j
connaissais rien la course à pied moi je
voyais des images du marathon de new
york ceux de la france et ça je voyais
des images qu'il y avait monsieur madame
tout le monde qui faisait le marathon de
new york dès des jeunes des plus âgés dé
plus en forme de mon enfant mais je me
suis dit moi aussi loin qu ai je fait un
moratoire en quatre heures
on reviendra à confiner à la corse en
gaspésie mais par rapport aux oubliés
parce qu'ils étaient plutôt on parlait
de
du rhône mentale en fait pitié de
continuer même dans la douleur que c'est
une phase qui va faire passer mais quand
est ce qu'on sait que la douleur c'est
juste une douleur qui est normal verse
une douleur qui dangereuse pour ton
corps l'expérience aussi quand tu
commences à découvrir et puis tu entouré
de professionnels de la santé de physio
de médecins du sport de qui rôdent ostéo
sens capable de mettre des mots sur sur
ce que ce que tu as quelque part dans
ton corps ils vont te dire ça c'est une
petite inflammation ça va passer si tu
fais ça ça c'est c'est un début de
fracture de stress ou ça peut c'est un
syndrome qui peut se transformer en
vraie blessure donc avec l'expérience et
le temps tu fini par savoir sur quand tu
ressens quelque chose sur ton corps si
c'est un petit truc parasites ou un
petit bobo qui va passer d'un autre jour
ou si haut la tension faut que je tire
un petit peu laplug que je réduise un
petit peu mon volume que je transfère
sur de la natation du vélo parce que ça
pourrait se transformer en blessure donc
la réponse et l'expérience des carmes en
sélection tu te connectes de plus en
plus à ton corps et tu sais tout de
suite tu sais tout de suite où tu en es
lorsque tu ressens quelque chose si
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
prendre en compte et s'occuper où vous
passez au travers poussé là dessus ça va
passer
[Musique]
ruff dans un à caen ce n'est
fait que rend la très banale histoire
c'est ça très banal donc on est en 2016
et j'ai vu mon papa viennent visiter au
québec et puis on part faire le road
trip gaspésienne classique tout le tour
de la côte l'alliance et on s'arrête la
pointe de la gaspésie donc le parc de
forillon fait la petite randonnée là
parce que fo parquet la voiture un peu
avant et j'arrive au pied du phare au
bout et là il ya le panneau il ya le
panneau sec explique le gr à 1 là où il
ya la carte et puis il ya toute
l'histoire de la randonnée qu'est ce que
c'est les gr km 0 c'est kilomètre zéro
et 5 kilomètre zéro donc c'est là le
blues il arrivé si tu continues tu
tombes dans l'eau le boubou lapointe et
là c'est écrit gr grc un label ça veut
dire grande randonnée c'est un label qui
donnait par la fédération française de
randonnée où il faut que le sentier
respecte certains critères de beauté de
paysages de refuge de voile à fauqué des
critères à respecter pour avoir le label
et puis après tu as des randonneurs qui
toute leur vie c'est d'aller faire tout
légère possible du monde entier je
dirais que la plupart sont en europe et
en amérique du nord c'est le seul qui a
été labellisé pour l'instant rjr à un an
grande randonnée américain et le seul
c'est au québec donc et puis j'ai vu ce
panneau gelé pris en photo et j'ai même
retrouvé cette photo sur mon celle de
2016 là mais je me suis dit qu'un jour
ce serait cool que je fasse des bouts de
ce gr en randonnée d'experts voient là
t'es pas jaloux et
après éventuellement avec le temps j'ai
commencé parce que ce moment là je
faisais même pas du trail tu vois donc
pour ça je pensais rand'auchel même pas
que ça existait mobilité de courir entre
elles puis quand j'ai découvert le monde
du treil le plus en 2010 est où j'ai vu
elle est un peu les les
les vedettes de ce milieu kilian jornet
françois d'haene de ce monde où j'ai
découvert qu'il ne faisait pas que des
courses cadre à proprement parler mais
qu'il faisait aussi des aventures hors
course personnel vous avez des quêtes
qui était pas uniquement de performance
mais aussi de découverte toute cette
dimension d'aventuré où tu perds un peu
le contrôle août à ce danger août a pas
de protection médicale ou c'est toi qui
doit organiser ton départ ton arrivée
des ravitaillements mais cela me suis
dit moi aussi un jour j'aimerais
vraiment faire faire une aventure hors
course
mais voilà peut-être baissé à fond dans
les courses parce que la première fois
qu'on t'invite à l'autre bout du monde
qu'on ne paye t avion et tout tout est
en train de dire oui il ya trop bien et
j'avais mis un petit peu de ça de côté
et puis voilà mars 2020 j'ai une saison
de course de fous à l'international et
puis qu'ovide jeter les uns derrière les
autres je reçois des courriels des
directeurs de course qui me disent bay
matt courses annulées et je pense que ça
a pris trois jours pour que je me dise
en fait c'était vraiment tout s'est
aligné le gouvernement du québec
commencé à dire vous allez plus dans le
sud vous quittez plus territoire sinon
ça va être compliqué de repasser la
frontière dans l'autre sens
tout ça fait que ok mais qu'est ce que
je vais faire de mon année j'ai envie de
courir j'ai envie de faire des amis de
me dépasser et puis le gr et tout d'un
coup apparu comme une révélation une
évidence que 2020 c'est ça que j'allais
faire faire comme mes idoles qui ont
fait sur d'autres sentiers aux états
unis ou encore swire dans le monde moi
aussi je veux essayer mon aventure hors
course de faire quelque chose de grand
qui le dépasse qui me fait peur dont
j'ai aucun contrôle et qui est
totalement expérimental et puis c'est ça
je me suis assis à table sur six grandes
maps et puis j'ai commencé à bûcher là
dessus et ça a été ça a été une aventure
incroyable parce que c'est sûr que dans
le confiner tu vois surtout un tout
petit peu avant parce qu'il commence en
mars mais on pense surtout aux pendant
mais le avant ça a été un travail
fresneau phénoménal faut être un
entrepreneur tu montes une équipe
thaddée budget à gérer et à des projets
pas du matériel de la sécurité les
assurances dans les calendriers ccsn
c'est phénoménal
je prends ton sac pour y aller à une
course est facile tu vas une course puis
on te met sous l'heure de départ et
[ __ ] des ravitaillements et ça c'est
facile mais là c'est où c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de travail tu as le pendant et
puis tu as le après que j'ai découvert
aussi que je ne savais pas du tout
imaginé c'est tout l'impact que tu peux
avoir en termes de communication sur le
projet à travers des médias classiques
des blogs et puis un film vidéo qui au
début en fait dès le réalisateur il est
venu et puis on commençait à tourner
dans montréal des images tous les avis
parce qu'il y avait aucune n'y avait
aucun charade les images parce que tu
cours d'un big roar très romancé faisait
sherbrooke ou orner les vexe puis à 5 km
en plein milieu pas une voiture et puis
on disait mais un faux film et ça et
puis c'est de là que c'est parti et j'ai
pu en hadji mais on va filmer tout ce
qui va se passer dans la préparation la
rodman un peu de dénivelé sur le mont
royal
l'aventuré en elle même et on verra ce
qu'on en fait après et c'est drôle ce
que tu disais qu'à nature et ça me
touche beaucoup parce que t'es pas le
premier à me dire et puis beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de québécois me l'ont
dit
jérôme mathieu merci pour les images que
vous avez sorti de la gaspésie parce que
pour nous la gaspésie c'est les
crevettes de matane c'est le mans saint
pierre c'est c'est la microbrasserie de
percer et puis le rocher percé mais le
coeur de la gaspésie le milieu là où il
ya les montagnes ou n'y a pas d'image
très très peu d'image parce que c'est
compliqué d'aller chercher les images
c'est trop hostile il ya tout le temps
du vin c'est humide il fier des mouches
qui mange tout et caméras elles ont plus
de batterie et le font ici tu sais tu es
jérôme pour aller prendre un six majeur
et puis il ya aussi une histoire de
permis aussi il fallait être accepté par
ces gérés par des parcs donc faire lever
le drone tu peux pas faire ça faut des
autorisations spéciales très compliqué
et donc je me rappelle je faire une
parenthèse à tulle m'appelle quand
j'écoutais lequel vous allez voir au
cinéma du musée ici à montréal puis on
l'appelle en voyant les images me passer
la réfection de
on a vraiment rien vraiment rien à
envier à nulle part ailleurs au monde en
terme de paysage le tir parce que j'y
tiens on regarde des fois des vidéos de
drones
dans les alpilles honduras et dumb au
pire mais honnêtement des paysages comme
ce quelqu'un qui habite pas au québec
voit sa fille derived de venir au québec
100% pour y aller ça pour cent et puis
c'est exactement ce que tu viens de dire
je les ai reçus comme commentaire très
souvent et ça en france voir la balle au
québec ça a rien à envier
n'importe quel appui pour avoir eu la
chance de pas mal crapahuter à travers
le monde tu as un contraste sur sur
cette gaspésie en terme de paysage et de
météo qui des deux extrêmes put jamais
vu ça ailleurs tu peux avoir de la forêt
très dense dans la jungle quand tout
d'un coup tu es dans une forêt de pins
comme dans les alpes quand tout d'un
coup tu es au sommet du mans jacques
cartier ou cd roche alpine où il ya plus
d'art parce que comme quintin altitude
tellement alberta l'impression d'être
sur mars un peu comme si tu allais sur
les afriques d'un certain rift talent
océans à côté d'un coup tu arrives au
bord de l'océan comme cet été sur la
côte j'ai pas ou en floride ou en
californie
cette diversité elle est malade quoi sur
650 km le tour du monde enfin pas besoin
de faire le vrai tour du monde par par
bas par une attitude mais vraiment sur
les 650 km tu vois tout et c'est ça donc
à la fin de l'aventuré rome il est venu
à la maison prendre un café et m'a dit
matt j'ai mille heures de vidéos là j'ai
mille heures de vidéos faut faire un
film d'une heure qu'est ce qu'on fait et
on aurait pu partir dans tellement
direction parce qu'ils avaient tous les
sujets possibles et le sujet facile que
tu vas souvent retrouvés dans les films
de sports de freeride en ski de trail de
mountain bike de ce que tu veux souvent
souvent souvent souvent et tournées sur
sur la performance sur la douleur sur
voilà parce que c'est c'est fou c'est ça
ça impressionne c'est spectaculaire tu
vois et au début je pensais pas partir
là dessus aussi parce que parce que
j'étais fier de ce que j'avais fait tu
vois et et puis à les faire se sentir là
en sept jours alors que ça prend en
moyenne 30 40 jours pour le faire tu
vois je t'ai pas peu fier de ce que
j'avais réussi à faire deux par tout le
travail que j'avais donnée là c'était
pas c'était quand même énorme
mais très vite on a décidé de parler là
ne pas aller là parce qu'on s'est dit ok
ce qu'on va faire plutôt que de dessiner
le scénario on va plutôt c'est essayer
de se donner des objectifs de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut montrer et
les deux principaux objectifs qu'on
s'est donné c'est de montrer d'abord la
beauté du territoire d'à gaspésie
centrale parce que il n'y avait pas
d'imagés puis même nous moi quand j'ai
préparé laventure j'aime faire de la
visualisation j'étais paca pas tout sur
google images rien quelques images mais
aucune idée qu est-ce qu à quoi ça
ressemblait donc quand ces dix là il
faut vraiment aller faire un travail
aussi de de recherchistes et puis de
création de contenu qui n'existe pas
pour montrer la beauté du territoire aux
québécois mais aussi au monde entier
donc ça c'est voilà un choix d'image
déjà là dessus et
le deuxième objectif c'est que on veut
que à la fin des milliers de personnes
qui ont vu le film on dépasse 50% de
personnes qui ne sont pas des coureurs
mais grand public mais moi quand tu ne
sais pas si c'est aller au cinéma du
musée j étais ou pas non non les chalets
etc ainsi revenue après mais je suis
allé en septembre pour faire quelques
projections et puis je faisais un petit
pitch en début de conférence et à chaque
fois je demandais dans la salle levez la
main ceux qui sont pas couvrir dans la
salle jeter en 70 80 pour sa personne
objectif atteint et le but voilà c'était
que c'était surtout ces personnes là que
je voulais entendre qu'on voulait
entendre
2 qu'est ce que vous a inspiré le film
tu vois des
c'est très basique mais on utilise la
course à pied quelques
la randonnée la course à pied un truc de
tripes banal pour illustrer des valeurs
et puis de vie et puis de dépassement de
soi et de communautés d'amour d'amitié
qu'ils peuvent
ce extrapoler à tous milieux de vie
voilà une sorte une sorte d'enseignement
en utilisant quelque chose de
illustré en images et de beau et pas un
livre c'est de développement personnel
ou de marketing trop complexes ou si
t'as pas fait des études ou city connaît
pas dans le domaine tu veux au bout de
trois pages tu dis trop compliqué là et
est ce que là bas tu le vois tu ressens
des choses tu vois par l'image qui fait
que voilà c'était ça et puis on a été en
été on a été assez content parce que ça
a été ce que c'est ce que ça a donné tu
vois mais ça a été le choix d'image là
et puis quelle question tu poses dans
les interviews pour pour t'amener là
c'est c'est de la répu là le réalisateur
c'est un sacré casse tête et moi je lui
tire mon chapeau parce que pour rallier
toutes ces images et puis faire réussir
à monter ce buzz là c'est quelque chose
de très fort dans que ouais c'est ma
plus belle aventure avis à date humaine
sportive
médiatique c'est très très fort et puis
ça résonne encore fort en nous et voilà
j'ai découvert qu' il n'y a pas que la
course soit sur la vie que aller faire
des
engagés dans notre porte sous un autre
angle très très fort aussi mais
aujourd'hui ça y est c'est en moi
[Musique]
on a plein d'autres républicains qui ont
démarré là et qui vont arriver dans les
années à venir faut retrouver un
équilibre entre les courses et autant de
chances on allait rester dans le film
aussi que tout ce qui aurait pu arriver
est arrivé le dans ce sens que les
intempéries étaient aussi ça j'ai
l'impression ou juste le fait de pau est
exactement savoir c'est très long qui
est sur papier 40 kilomètres ça va te
prendre cinq heures ça va me prendre
finalement c'est plutôt 10 heures que
cinq heures
c'est une belle allégorie comme ceux
dits de la vie en fait le fils de qui je
m'attendais que ce soit sur mais
finalement c'est plus difficile permet
qu'on continue quand même si mes mille
raisons mille raisons par jour c'est sûr
si on le voit vraiment dans ces moments
les plus difficiles aussi les plus
sombres parce que tu le vois que tu as
passé à un cheveu aussi d'abandonner
peter puis mais c'est la beauté de
devoir prendre un instant pour réfléchir
à ce puits finalement décidé de
consigner faire une sieste de 20 minutes
la scène
a marqué séquentielle de 10 minutes dans
le temps est complètement en été il ya
plus la notion du temps c'est dans ces
moments là bas tu as dû peut-être le
vivre quand tu as fait un peu de d'ultra
là le temps peut se compresser qu'un ça
va super bien comme s'étirer très très
lent quand ça va pas du tout et à ce
moment là en dix minutes ça veut ça veut
plus rien dire quoi c mais c'est ça qui
est très très beau dans le film
d'aventuré je trouve contrairement à un
film classique c'est que tu es dans la
spontanéité l'authenticité et puis on ne
sait pas d'avancé un film à être bon pas
parce que ça dépend d'eux qu'est ce qui
va se passer quelle magie va arriver
qu'elle quelles péripéties va arriver tu
sais pas est ce que tu vas prendre une
tempête pas de tempête est ce que ça va
être dur pas dur et c'est ça qui est
beau c'est que c'est pas stadiers dans
une salle pour tourner du cinéma tu vas
pouvoir répéter la scène dix fois
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient parfaites là
le film séduit one day one shot à aucun
moment jérôme mahdia temps repart en
arrière la repasse la non non c'est ta
une chose puis c'est la chose la plus
spontanée que tu peux faire c'est ça qui
est beau aussi que tu ne manques pas tu
montes pas après sur ce que tu racontes
c'est vraiment
puis moi quand j'ai au moins j'ai quitté
le film en fait
c'était le le départ de ma rencontre
avec toi mais ton qui ne recherchent pas
aussi pour le podcast c'est donc en fait
je savais rien donc j'avais même pas si
tu finissais la course avait rien dit
puis le film moi de rien savoir je l' ai
vécu quand même comme un thriller parce
qu'il ya des moments qui dit ça sans
vent de la mer j'ai toutes les filles
meetic un moment où tout paraît aussi où
ton équipe tu repars puis de regarder ce
thème à blanc du scipion tech systems
est récente qu'est ce qui va se passer
et puis c'est à chaque jour on se
demander qu'est-ce qu'elle avait dû
invoquer le nouvel obstacle qui va
arriver quelqu'un l'intempérie va se
passer de ces pays c'est vraiment
c'était moins vraiment quelque chose d
comme comme écouter témoin on aime bien
coûter le tour de france et pis si ça
pulse est toujours des revirements des
surprises puis des des cours sur
plusieurs jours comme ça ouais c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment vraiment
stressant c'est vraiment
le fun à regarder le pilote ça va plus
loin que
documentaire une performance dans sa
salle était sale et et stressant et puis
je crois que à partir du moment où tu te
lances sur des projets professionnels
sportifs peu importe qui dépasse un peu
où t'as pas le contrôler ou tepa experts
là dedans on sait à peu près
expérimental pour toi parce que c'est
nouveau c'est sûr qu'il va t'arriver des
choses dix jours qui va t'arriver des
choses est ce que cette course là est ce
que cette randonnée le il ya d'autres
qui l'ont fait en mode le terminer le
plus rapidement possible aux
c'est ça qui est beau aussi c'est que tu
tues sebo dans un cheminement de de
lancer aussi comme des mouvements d'être
un petit peu précurseur pour aller ça la
marche et si c'est beau parce que c'est
moi l'impression que ma mission de vie
aujourd'hui plus à des personnes qui me
disent elles grâce à des images j'ai eu
le goût d'aller prendre une marche de la
montagne dans la nature c'est ça voilà
et effectivement donc c'est un sentier
qui était essentiellement randonnée qui
avait jamais été courues donc j'étais le
premier à nancy là dessus c'est assez
complexe parce que la fenêtre est assez
courte iliad à neige encore sûrement
jacques cartier qui a joint donc c'est
juillet juillet août la la la la fenêtre
et tu préféré y aller en août parce
qu'un juillet les mouches noires elles
sont vraiment déjà en août c'était
compliqué l'allemand vraiment mener la
vie dure mais en juillet c'est encore
pire et apparaît en septembre la chasse
reprend donc tu peux pas t'en l'annoncé
très court ça te prend quand même du
temps à préparer du temps sur place donc
c'est pas tout le monde qui peut se
lancer dans des aventures comme ça faut
avoir une famille et puis un
environnement de vie quitte le permet
est donc juste après vient après moi
c'est c'est une fille qui a été le faire
et elle l'a fait donc dans le monde des
fps qui fastest un long time il ya
plusieurs catégories moi j'ai fait une
catégorie en gros au supporter où
j'avais un coup qui venait apporter de
la nourriture et puis des vêtements là
où il pouvait me croisent et qui était
assez rare quand même dans le sentier
mais en at il eu des passages et donc
c'est charlotte pas qu'elle croit faudra
vérifier l'a fait en catégorie e2
supported c'est à dire que la tortue la
tortue avec sa carapace 62 tout avec
elle son sleeping c'est qu'elle dormait
dans un hamac et puis c'est ça et puis
sa nourriture sa nourriture elle l'avait
fait développer dans des dans des boxes
en bois anti ours sur le chemin et moi
quand j'ai écouté ça là que j'ai appris
ça je me suis dit et comment elle a fait
parce que c'est tellement humide c'est
tellement mieux quand arrive le soir tes
pieds sont fripé comme si tu avais passé
10 heures dans un bain chaud c'était
envie de se sécher un peu tu vois et
puis quand tu dors dehors la kiss et
humide battue reste humide tu vois et
puis ça a répété fois le prix plus dix
jours là whaou l'impressionnant donc
cette fille a fait ça il ya notre gars
qui a fait aussi à peu près en même
temps qu'elle sous cette forme là après
on a une très bonne coureurs au québec
s'appelle en bouche heures qu'il l'a
fait aussi donc ça y est le mouvement
est parti puis c'est génial c'est génial
c'est ces foules mais ça me dépasse
honnêtement ça me dépasse des choses
comme ça quand dans le film et on le
voit c'est des images prises avec qui et
vos cellulaires je pense bousquet tête
avec quelqu'un qui taille d'un peu bien
pêchue relation me que vous êtes comme
pris dans une tempête sur une petite
cabine au sommet du mont joie avec
jacques cartier au sommet du mont
jacques cartier pis le [ __ ] l'art
d'être
l'accouchement ce moment alors que total
potentiel que vous êtes toute rampe
je sais qu'un bon je sais pas exactement
quand la tempête va arrêter mais on est
on est coincé ici ça paraît on dirait
que ce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de
comme la fluctuation des niveaux
d'énergie dans une course de 20 heures
là c'est vraiment la situation au niveau
d'énergie sur sept jours complets parce
que parce que ça revient ça finit par
revenir c'est l'expérience que tu
parlais de dire parce que moi mettons au
sommet de cette montagne là je fais
quand même vous venez me chercher le
genre c'est terminé les oublis sommet
mais toi probablement que tu es capable
de dire ça va ça va revenir j'étais à
deux doigts de j'avais sécurité un
tracker gps avec un bouton sos était
vraiment à deux doigts de d'appuyer
dessus j'ai pleuré j'ai beaucoup pleuré
dans les images j'ai juste film et le
moment parce que j'étais vraiment un
mois de pleurer solide j'ai pas filmer
ça parce que j'étais vraiment c'était
pas possible et le moment où ça allait
un peu mieux j'ai réussi à me filmer un
peu j'ai dit ça il faut quand même que
je le jeu le document c'est dur est de
sortir son téléphone ou ou une caméra
quand tu pleures parce que deux tu
arrives pas en fait à parler à mon très
simple et la cabane au sommet du mans
jacques cartier nous a sauvés c'est pas
sale aventure c'est sûr qu'on s'arrêtait
en appui sur la source puis on espère
sauver
c'est
c'est des moments qui peuvent arriver
puis puis j'ai pas des fois je me dis je
crois a fait un faux faut toujours avoir
un espoir et croire en cette belle
étoile puis cette cabane qui est arrivé
là ça a été ça nous ça nous à nous à
sauver cette cabane un petit chaque
adresse un petit refuge en boîte parce
qu'en fait le mans jacques cartier a
cette particularité d'être souvent pris
dans la tempête il ya comme un film
phénomène météorologique local
microclimat qui fait ça et et puis quand
tu es bête un avis très il est un petit
short tests et quand la tempête elle
bonne il ya de la pluie du vent de la
brume tout d'un coup il fait moins 5 et
tu peux pas courir pour réchauffer parce
que c'est si tu l'as vu c'est un monde
de roche qui glissent comme tu courais
sur des savants dépit des roches points
de suture tombe là dessus tu te qu'une
coupe en deux en fait donc faut tenter
de tenir les qui dit mais ça fait déjà
cinq jours que tu cours tu as fait 500
km et épuisés et fait froid tu là j'ai
envie de pleurer un camarade chemin donc
en plus ton cerveau ne fonctionne plus
tu as plus de lucidité n'y a pas de
chemin tu avances juste en regardant les
cairns donc des petits tas de roches qui
sont gris pareil que les roches cas par
terre sauf que comme ennahdha brume tu
ne vois pas tu sais plus où fois la
droite à gauche ton pays certes on
accompagne heures et commence à être
glacée aussi ils voient plus le truc est
tous là tu dis mais ne fais mourir
mourir d'un coup c'est plus drôle moi je
moi je fais ça pour aussi pour prendre
du plaisir le fun puis quand je me lâche
car d'arranger l'âge sans danger c'est
pas je sais reconnaître le moment où
c'est un danger qui peut être vraiment
dangereux on va dire et où le plus de
fun et là puis pour moi quand j'arrive
là c'est qu'il est vraiment dangereux
jeter
mais ça fait partie de l'aventuré après
il ya un an n'est pas non plus un
concert dans le sens où tu es
aujourd'hui tous les aventuriers on part
tous avec personne ne parlera sans gps
tracker aujourd'hui moi ça
m'impressionne plus un gars qui va en
antarctique au pôle nord ou non droit il
perd reculer parce qu'il est un gps
plein coeur il appelle il a pu s'en sort
un saut est puis une heure deux heures
après tu as quelqu'un qui arrive moi ce
qui m'impressionne surtout c'est des
vrais explorateurs des attentats en
arrière qui partait faire ces trucs là
ce sens un gps tracker ça veut dire
qu'il soit un expert polaire ou quoi
qu'il leur arrive quelque chose bien ils
sont tout seul tout seul nous soit donc
aujourd'hui on a quand même cette porte
de sortie qu'il faut pas oublier dans le
monde de l'aventuré un peu des défis
hors normes on peut dire de l'extérieur
ils sont complètement fou de faire ça à
mettre leur vie en danger c'est débile
wallemme l'a bien j'ai pu à ce tracker
qui est souvent redondants aussi qui est
connecté à voilà aux services de secours
local et que dépendamment août et sur le
monde ça va pas prendre plus de trois
jours pour reviens te chercher à moins
que tu sois vraiment je pense que les
pires endroits c'est en très haute
altitude parce que dans l'himalaya les
hélicoptères avec l'oxygène peuvent pas
se rendre depuis c'est compliqué ou peut
avoir d une météo encore plus extrême
mais globalement dans le monde tu peux
venir te faire chercher même si tu es
assez reculée d'un milieu urbain tu vois
donc voilà c'est une prise de risque
mais qui n'est pas non plus totalement
inconsciente voilà il n'est même quand
on voit les images du premier gars qui
monter l'everest les genres un petit 6
cotler de cuir est simple tu vois
maintenant aujourd'hui son regard les
masses d'oxygène est gros et vittek lui
un petit cours de cuir est promis
qu'il ya ça aussi le matériel a
énormément évolué clairement un tulle
dit fin c'est l'everest et puis tu tu
vois comment il était habillé
en janvier on a des matériaux des
gore-tex des plumes le truc dans mon
manteau c'est hyper légers dégâts
énormes dans même des peut même avoir
des résistances électriques pour pour se
chauffer dans tes vêtements
quand même c'est quand même
impressionnant mais on va pas dire que
c'est confortable ça c'est très très
costaud mais c'est plus du tout
c'est pas que c'est pas comparable en
terme d'engagement de deux folique ce
que faisait les aventures et les jeunes
explorateurs 50 ans n'a clairement cette
année est aussi fait le légendaire
marathon des sables ce mois parce que
moi c'était après l' utmb fait que j'ai
commencé à suivre puis le j'ai vu cette
histoire lors de marathons désole que
j'avais déjà entendus mais peux tu
expliquer c'est quoi le marathon des
sables dans son essence à ceux qui nous
écoutent en ce moment parce que ça aussi
c'est une autre affaire complètement
folle le marathon des sables c'est une
grosse bête au milieu du monde de l'
aventure s'est pas uniquement dans la
communauté des coureurs le marathon des
sables fait partie c'est des fois il ya
des ya un peu des
personnes qui veulent un peu sortir de
leur zone de confort équivalent à taper
sur sur un moteur de recherche
comme un défi les plus extrêmes sur
terre tu vois et puis souvent tu vas
retrouver le marathon des sables donc
c'est pas que dans la communauté de
coureurs et le concept est de traverser
bien une partie du sahara donc
milieu des plus extrêmes en termes de
chaleur et d'hostilité au monde
sur sur plusieurs jours dans une
autonomie quasi totale c'est à dire que
l'organisation va te fournir uniquement
de l'eau donc tu as une semaine pour
traverser entre 250 300 km dans le sable
avec zéro ambre 0 et tu dois réfléchir
aussi à qu'est ce que tu vas prendre
avec toi dans son sac comme nourriture
comme t'as pas de tapas de maisons non
plus là tu dors par terre les quins mal
éteinte vous suivre c'est ça il se
déplace on le matin on part et puis
parce que c'est un cépage boucle c'est
un point pour un bain d'huile et jours
et puis on reporte toujours du même
endroit donc quand tu pars le matin ils
prennent le campement avec les petites
tentes berbères et il est lé transfert à
l'arrivée ainsi de suite mais ces
spartiates s etc etc des militantes
c'est une toile et c'est même pas faire
mais c'est une toile qui est tendu où tu
as de bord puis le vent des deux côtés
puis la nuit qu'il ya une tempête de
sable czerny terme en jeu toute la nuit
et donc c'est ça
mais c'est assez extrêmes ben
c'est ce que tu peux imaginer dans le
désert dans le sable il peut faire des
températures extrêmes le sable est mou
donc chaque fois que tu essaies de
courir un peu comme dans la neige la
sata certaine énergie a pas de rebond
têtu sont là dessus vous le pied ce
vendredi mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ça fait encore plus monter la chaleur
interne puis en fait moi ça m'a rendu
fou la chaleur c'est la première fois
que j'ai déjà eu chaud dans ma vie mais
je trouve que le show est plus dur que
le froid c'est ce que j'ai découvert au
marathon et ça parce que le froid je vis
à montréal puisque c'est les moins 40 tu
peux tu peux te couvrir pour pas avoir
froid tu vois ta ta ta une solution mais
quintas chiots vieux ténue ténue tu vois
il n'y a plus rien à faire et dans le
désert n'y a pas d'ombré il n'ya pas
dont il n'y a pas un arbre ya pas un
rocher et quant à chaud ça te rend fou
parce que là tu dis habituellement des
deux quintés dans quelque part ou tâches
où tu vas
tu vas te mettre à l'ombre tulle et de
beignets tu vas te mettre dans l'eau
boire faire quelque chose mais là il n'y
a rien et ça rend vraiment fou le mot là
je pèse mes mots ça peut te rendre fou
tu vois tu commences à divaguer et puis
et tu cherches le mirage quoi comme dans
les aventures
et c'est une grosse introspection le
désert c'est c'est plus que c'est plus
qu'un simple défi physique c'est il ya
un casse tête là dedans aussi etc
voyant une vidéo de gameplay qui est un
des meilleurs
ultramarathoniens au monde qui qui se
prépare pour la chaleur puis il fait 40
degrés celsius ou skis et puis il ya
deux heures de chant à faire pour aller
vers la turquie veut s'entraîner il se
met dans son char il ferme les fenêtres
puis il descend sans air climatisé fait
que j'appelais il se fait filmer par le
gars qui fument périgueux qui firmly
puis à parier qu'apple réclamé au début
de la vidéo this erreurs que je parle
dans mes vidéos mais faut que je vous
explique ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
allait y explique ce qui s'est passé
puis sont arrivés au lieu où est-ce que
normalement j'aurais filmer son training
dit j'ai juste un délire elle j'ai pu
capable de filmer son trinket lui fait
ça il compte deux ans dans son champ il
fait 3 heures de course à 40 degrés
celsius germain sochaux s'est préparé
pour la chaire l'ordre
dimdim est un athlète d'ultra endurance
aussi et donc c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure a aussi aujourd'hui je
pense une connexion avec son corps ou
tel que il a compris que le corps humain
a une capacité d'adaptation incroyable
mais vraiment c'est ça dépasse
l'entendement et puis il faut le vivre
pour le comprendre et
et c'est ça en fait il faut il faut lui
apprendre au corps et tu le vois moi
quand j'arrive au sahara et puis y avait
des marocaines locaux qui habitent là et
pas de problème avec ce serait un
problème pas de lunettes de soleil pas
de casquette et transpire même pas y tu
dis mais
on est pareil quand on est humain tu
vois et puis tu apprends que voilà ton
corps ce qui fait jim là c'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour pour créer une sorte
d'accoutumance
[Musique]
active et la terminera thermorégulation
de ton corps pour pouvoir passer à
travers ça ne s'est pas c'est vrai que
quand tu rates sa dexter tu dit
complètement fou pourquoi il fait ça ce
gala est mais non en fait parce qu'il
sait que la capacité d'adaptation est
énorme dans tout dans le show dans le
froid dans la douleur dans
l'adaptation tissulaire des muscles et
articulations tout tout tout tout peut
s'adapter c'est faux et inversement
gellik le contre-exemple jeu que j'ai
plein de monde dans mon entourage qui
ont fait la traversée du lac saint-jean
petit défaut il fait à saint claud est à
56 degrés fahrenheit puis pendant huit
heures tcc du stock puis dans la
préparation ces débats glace puis cédé
douche glacée puis c'est de rester
longtemps dans ces conditions là à tous
les jours tu 1 20 minutes dans un bain
glacé bleu tu t'habitues tranquillement
into tout c'est une machine complexe le
corps est à l'hôtel tout le système
nerveux qui électrique connexion avec le
cerveau qui n'imaginait un comme
incompréhensible la machine physique et
puis le maître le
en fait dès que tu stimule en dehors de
ce qu' il a l'habitude de faire à tous
les jours il va créer une adaptation
est donc le stimule tu stimulant qui
stimule toujours dans une zone où tu es
pas bien il va s'adapter à cet assaut
stimuli que tu lui que tu lui impose
puis il ya un intervenant dans le même
temps qu'on finit qui explique un peu ce
domaine là aussi tic d'enfants que cd
d'inhiber les signaux que ton cerveau en
temps voilà finalement
d'être capable de vite on à bercy où
c'était qu'on avait reçues les physios
sur le podcast a expliqué que la douleur
est une émotion on dit que ton cerveau
sans voix comme mais comme n'importe
quelle émotion soir à peine c'est
possible justement avec en l'entraînant
2 2
ib de le comprendre
de jouer avec ça mais c'est blaise
dubois qui disent à qui et qui est le
fondateur de la clinique du corac et un
physio lui-même
mais ça ne rejoint ce que je disais
auparavant août à une forme
d'accoutumance qui peut se faire
vis-à-vis de la douleur et moi c'est une
quête que j'ai encore aujourd'hui
laquelle j'ai pas de réponse et où j'ai
eu du mal à trouver des réponses dans la
science
comme je disais on a on a tous ont
grandi tous dans une société qui est
assez protectrices qui fait que notre
barrière de protection est très très
loin de la véritable barrière de danger
donc quand tu commences à sortir un
petit peu de chez vous tu commences à un
petit peu la poussée la poussée cette
barrière mais en fait
d'après ce que dit blaise aussi c'est
que normalement le corps est assez bien
fait pour une fois que tu arrives à la
vraie barrière où tu vas te mettre en
danger la y aura quelque chose qui va
faire que tu vas devoir d'arrêter et moi
c'est une quête pour moi parce que je
suis jamais allé là encore elle et je
veux y aller mais en même temps c'est
quelque chose que je sais
c'est assez paradoxal parce que tu dis
mais non tu veux pas aller là parce que
tu mets en danger mais en même temps si
tu vas là on te dit que tu vas pas être
vraiment en danger parce que la vraie
barrière qu'elle va arriver tu vas tu
arrêter mais c'est une quête qui est
quand même intéressant de les limites
voilà les vrais les vraies limites on va
se dire la trouver la limite de trouver
la limite de l'être humain si tu joues
avec ses boeufs heures la fcc moi ça me
passionnait un de mes auteurs préférés
sur qui que j'ai étudié pendant la
maîtrise s'appelle hunter thompson lui
parler il faisait cette analyse là
exactement
la prendre une courbe en moto et d'y
prendre une courbe en moto il ya une
vitesse
qui va te faire tomber il y en a eu que
va faire tomber sauf que pour les seuls
qui savent c'est quoi cette vitesse le
cse qui sont passés par dessus oui fait
que c'est ce qu'ils ont qui sont tombés
qui sont sûrement totilas parce que si
tu l'as si tu y vas un petit peu plus
bas tu tombes affecte s'est passé
laquelle ça fait partie du film il en
est ça fait partie du cheminement aussi
de ce crash est un petit peu aussi parce
qu'ils se rendent compte que
c'est après ce crash là j'arrive à me
relever c'est que finalement c'était pas
celle là lâche mais si tu situe vraiment
tu peux pas te relever que t'as pas de
capacité de de prendre du recul sur ce
qui s'est passé pour reprendre ton
virage sous un autre angle avec une
autre limite basse et que c'était la
bonne la mairie ou la pas la vraie
limite tu vois mais c'est passionnant
[Musique]
réflexion le mode enfant juste arrivé
hier d'une semaine de vacances de pure
vacances vraiment tu es dans le lit
vraiment en mode tout inclus le tir pis
le jeu mais je réfléchisse à ce parce
que le thé c'est vraiment dans un monde
complètement artificielle ou est-ce que
tout est apte à porter tout le temps le
tough pointe juste à tendre la main puis
tu peux manger à volonté ses pieds c'est
tout est beau tout est vraiment fait
pour la vie sur le plus facile procès
qui lui jetaient le dans ce monde
artificiel où tout est
parfait serment tout est est il le plus
confortable possible
je me sentais peau à
ses dépens captifs me sentais pas
inspiré me sentais pas dans des
conditions parce que j'allais créer
quelque chose d'important ou deux outils
des grands le trident dans ce contexte
l'ue et puis je me suis mis à réfléchir
sur tte la plupart des arts des grands
artistes ou des grands
des personnes qui ont marqué l'histoire
joints tu regarde en arrière type lions
paul avis la plus facile les possibles
très souvent c c'est des gens qui ont eu
des débuts des grands obstacles qui ont
eu des difficultés qu'ils ont ici qu'ils
ont ici puisque ces difficultés les ont
poussés à créer ou les a amenés dans une
zone questions paul choix de faire
quelque chose pour se sortir de la
situation dans laquelle il était dit
même les entrepreneurs à succès il se
met en danger et c'est surtout le temps
puis comme tu dis dans la société où
est-ce qu'on est maintenant j'ai
l'impression que
on n'écarte pas ce qu'on en a le luxe le
plus possible les difficultés type il
les enfants qui grandissent aujourd'hui
il grandit dans un contexte beaucoup
plus facile que mettons un enfant bleu
300 noms ou à n'importe quel autre
époque j'imagine donc on la connaît
comme tu dis de moins en moins ces
difficultés là j'ai l'impression qu'on a
un peu besoin de la vivre pour
pour juste à être un humain un peu
oisifs le type est un peu justement tu
es sans sans aspiration plus que comme
juste exister exister vie existent et
puis juste comme vivre de plaisir en
plaisir mais tombe ce talent reste line
fac pige eu l'impression que
la course dans ce monde là où n'importe
quel support n'importe quel dépassement
avec difficulté le fond un puce canepa
qui nous est imposée s'est imposée soi
même c'est un peu ce que j'aimerais
c'est l'ultra trail ou n'importe quel
défi qu'on s'est lancé comme
je pense qu'on a besoin des difficultés
d'obstacles pour comme grandir puis vite
y en a de moins en moins il faut s'en
crée il soit peu partiellement les
réflexions mais non mais moi j'aime
chez moi j'aime beaucoup et puis je te
rejoins en fait ce que je veux te
répondre c'est que ce que tu as ressenti
dans le sud c'est que ton un stent
rattrape cette rattrapage de l'analyse
que j'en ai de ce que tu viens de dire
c'est que
on est notre société a évolué dans une
modernité beaucoup plus vite que notre
capacité à s'adapter à ce nouveau monde
là pour moi on est encore été je me pose
beaucoup beaucoup de questions je suis
passionné de de connaissances
scientifiques et puis il faut être très
humble là dedans parce qu'un jour on
peut dire que une étude ben voilà c'est
ça et puis tout d'un coup une nouvelle
étude arrive et puis non finalement
c'est pas ça donc oui il ya la
connaissance faut quand même rester
assez ouvert là dessus mais ça reste que
on vient on vient de la nature à
l'origine il n'y a pas si longtemps
finalement quand tu regardes à la
mutuelle voilà voilà on ne sait pas si
longtemps on était encore des nomades
dans le bois et à
pour vivre survivre à
faire de l'activité physique toute la
journée on parle pas de sport l'a juste
bout le mouvement corporel pour se
déplacer pour chasser pour fuir essayait
vraiment y'a pas si longtemps et souvent
quand je me pose des questions un peu
complexe sur ce sujet un sujet lié au
sport à la santé et puis j'y arrive pas
ça me fait mal à la tête il est les
études divergent convergent évidemment
je me pose je prends du recul je me dis
mais qu'est ce qui faisait le avant à
l'époque où il n'est pas tout cette
modernité autour de nous ces épiceries
la nourriture à profusion être ultra
confortable et je trouve des réponses
comme ça et aujourd'hui il ya il ya
quelques il ya quelques études qui
prouvent que on a des adaptations encore
aujourd'hui donc ça montre qu'il ya pas
si longtemps
de 2,2 musculaire
articulaires et puis puis tissulaire
pour courir comme pour courir pour se
déplacer et pas pour rester assis
longtemps on n'a pas encore le corps qui
est adapté à la position la position
assise lit aujourd'hui on essaie de
faire on s'adapte un petit peu peut-être
de manière contre nature à cette société
moderne mais on se fait rattraper par
part s'est installé pour rester dans mon
domaine là après il ya plus il ya plein
de dans la quête du bonheur il y en a
énormément avec possibilité d direction
mais justement rester dans le mien de
domaine
l'activité physique pour moi est vital
sur ta santé physique et mentale et la
connexion à la nature aussi donc c'est
pour ça que l'activité physique c'est
génial d'aller faire du sport de la
natation du basket du hand ball du
hockey mais tu es tu et à l'intérieur
dans une salle donc c'est bien mais il
faut rajouter cette couche aussi de
connexion la nature ni qui est vital
aussi pour moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas fait pour passer autant de
temps
derrière la gare entre des murs qui qui
nous qui nous qui nous qui nous séparent
du monde naturel et puis bon je crois
que la personne aujourd'hui quelqu'un il
va prendre une marche dans le bois qui
revient et payet pas trop bien cru
qu'ils étaient créatif c'est clair
qu'ils traînent dans le cerveau tes sens
sont en éveil et puis tu reviens tu es
heureux et je peux comprendre cette
moi je mets un petit peu moins
aujourd'hui parce que je passe tellement
de temps nature que j'ai j'ai oublié
cette sensation
d'étouffement et t2
d'affranchissement du besoin vital est
naturel et
c'est ça moi pour moi je l'analyse que
j'en ai de ce que tu as à nice et c'est
finalement ce voilà ce détachement à
notre instinct primaire
qui est encore trop présent en nous et
on ne sait pas encore à s'adapter à
cette modernité qui fait que ben on a
des dérives
physique de par des maladies ou là et
puis mental de par des troubles des
troubles divers qui se passe dans un
état critique c'est de retourner sa
mallette naturel c'est parce que c'est
parce que je dis mais c'est à la portée
de tout le monde dont 10 pas d'aller
habiter mais celle apportée tout le
monde aller prendre une marche et on
demande à découvrir des ultras d'aller
faire du vélo de la natation traversée
de lac saint jean mais juste d'aller
prendre
obligatoire moi je te dis là j'ai mon
calendrier qui très très très chargé
parce que je suis multi projets
interactifs mais dans mon calendrier là
quand je vais dans la nature offert mon
entraînement c'est un rendez vous
professionnel que j'ai écrit dans mon
calendrier et c'est le même rendez vous
que tu es tu vas tu vas chez le coiffeur
ou tu vas chez le banquier ou tu vas
faire une irm à l'hôpital tu le rates
pas ton rendez-vous tu vois où tu as un
rendez vous avec ton employeur ou je
sais pas quoi tu le rates pas mais moi
c'est un rendez-vous pour moi parce que
c'est mon rendez vous de santé physique
de rendez-vous mental y a personne qui
va il ya personne qui va prendre ce
rendez vous à cette place et puis quand
mon
téléphone il me dit un quart d'heure à
tâtons rendez vous avec toi même monta
santé ben j'y vais j'y vais il ya il ya
dans mon calendrier dans mon calendrier
à tous les jours et c'est ça cevital et
puis
moi ça moi ça me
le nombre d'heures qu'on passe à si ça
ne rend fou en fait elles et puis
j'étais là dedans aussi avant tu te
rends compte sur rade une journée assez
classique tu te lèves le matin tu
t'assois pour prendre ton café ou ton
petit-déjeuner tu prends ton char ou ton
métro prendra-t-on activité
professionnelle tahri est une activité
professionnelle assise le matin tu te
lèves pour les prendre un petit café
mais tu te ra soit encore jettera soit
pour l'entier tu te rassure l'après midi
tu te rassure dans ton char dans l'autre
sens du trad soit pour souper le soir tu
te rates raza pour garder ton est fixe
ou lire au niveau le soir moi je suis
mon avis mais je ressens que j'en ai pas
fier n'est pas fait pour ce mode de vie
là en est juste le fait qu'il soit venu
à la cour ce site était parti de chez
vous qui vient la course et c'est comme
inhabituelles en fait les branles
premiers invités qui font partie du
plateau qui est venu ici à course pis
mais c'est seulement au final c'est
comme le moyen de transport
d'abord le plus naturel puis on l'oubli
bis et c'est de
l'image on a pris moins de temps car ils
sont tarés permettront petite anecdote
quand j'étais dans mon bureau
d'ingénierie à ville saint-laurent le
mouvement qui s'appelait commune
training avais je pense que c'est un peu
à montréal que ça a démarré avec
quelques précurseurs de ça et puis j'ai
lu des articles lui dire bon aller au
travail et au courant mais je comprenais
pas tu vois j'avais la chance d'avoir
une douche au bureau je vais l'essayer
et effectivement en courant j'allais
plus vite qu'eux alors la voiture
pouvait être équivalent au vélo le jour
y est pas le trafic mais un jour 2 à une
heure de pointe trafic en courant
j'étais plus vite que si je faisais
voiture ou un métro plus ce changement
avec le bus donc un tu gagne du temps 2
je peux vous assurer est bon là c'est
l'expérience qui parle je peux pas le
prouver mais j'arrive au travail une
énergie gérer j'ai déjà dans ma tête
pense à ma journée à tous mes problèmes
je suis en réunion d'ouverture de la
journée hypercrack et puis que du
positif donc c'était devenu mais mon
mode de transport naturel de me déplacer
en courant et puis c'est vrai que dans
l'ingénieriste est complexe parce que
parfois j'avais des rendez vous avec des
clients ou ont parlé de projet à
plusieurs millions de dollars et puis la
convention on veut qu'il faut arriver
avec une cravate et à une chemise areva
tandis que salomon alors au début au
début ce que je faisais ce que je
transportais dans mon sac mais à la fin
je me disais expliqué en fait à mes à
mes clients et puis mes partenaires la
raison pour laquelle j'étais à j'avais
cet accoutrement là et c'était super
pour briser la glace et puis les gardes
auraient en fait et puis et puis il
n'estimait pas la qualité de notre de
notre de notre travail d'ingénierie a
finalement notre habillement notre
habillement et puis puis depuis ce jour
j'ai je lui ai mis mon costard cravate
d'amont armoiries au fond de l'armoire
je l'aimais plus ressortie imagine la
révolution le même thème est on si tout
le monde à montréal se mettaient à court
et où
on se déplace en vélo comment le monde
aurait on résout tellement de problèmes
de 100 m tu prêches l'environnement tu
as vraiment à imaginer une révolution la
plus grande révolution qui pense que la
plus grande révolution du sort
c'est facile à dire mais courir c'est
pas facile faire du vélo c'est pas
facile
la ville est pas et pas du tout encore
adapté à ça c'est clairement surtout en
amérique du nord c'est la voiture qui
est qui qui règne là dedans et puis tout
le temps de dois te faire tuer quand tu
roules fait que sur ce qui s'est passé
mais c'est sûr elle mal de matches que
tu prennes convaincu que se bouger enfin
faire de l'activité physique de partons
de déplacement pour les deux mois un
point b
c'est clairement vital mais moi je peux
comprendre aussi celui qui toujours été
un petit peu sédentaires qui a du mal à
s'y mettre et qui a un environnement
urbain qui n'est pas du tout adapté à
cette pratique là
ça me fait capoter mais en même temps tu
es toi c'est 100 kg de chez-vous 5 kg
c'est très accessible c'est pour
quelqu'un mais c'est pourquoi que jamais
rien que
m au bout de deux mois c'est le solo qui
faisait très facile à faire sans même
transpiré de manière très confortable si
tu regardes dans une zone assez basse je
n'ai pas transpiré en venant ici j'ai
écouté un petit podcast et puis et puis
c'est ça tu sais
ce moment là c'est même pas une pierre
deux coups c'est une pierre sang coup
c'est tu vas tu vas être créatif donc
pour créer des projets dingue j'ai des
fois je me dis faut que je facture mais
demi heure de course le nombre de deux
le projet que j'ai développé dans mes
moments parce que tu es avec toi même il
ya aucun tu remarqueras quand tu es chez
vous en voiture tu as toujours une
interaction avec un panneau publicitaire
une affaire qui notifie quelque part qui
fait que tu arrive jamais à rentrer
profonde profondément dans dans une
réflexion de créativité ou de résolution
de problématiques puis quand il va faire
du sport du vélo de la course à pied t
c'est vraiment un moment avec toi même
qu'il ya personne qui va venir déranger
là dedans on est vraiment au dessus du
col de téléphone à face et que tu
actives les notifications il va pas ils
vont continuer à étonner mais je fais
des fortes coupes et anton vibrato raid
avec moi même et on dirait que
le fait d'être dans une dans un
mouvement en fait qui est un peu plus
rapide que fin que l'arrêt
ouvre ouvre d ouvre des portes de
réflexion qui facilite le voilà la
créativité la réflexion donc qui sait ça
et
c'est
un enchaînement en fait c'est un peu tu
dis ouais mais c'est l'oeuf et la poule
est ce que je peux pas aller faire du
sport parce que je suis pas en santé tu
vois j'ai pas la capacité mais en fait
non comme fait le sport et puis tu vas
être en santé est quelque chose que tu
peux le niveau est toujours quelque
chose que tu peux faire pour te dépasser
ne serait ce que pour un autre après de
rien mais pour toi ça peut être juste
quelque chose qui ont paru chaque chaque
la lèpre en soignant son objectif est un
objectif l'ambition d'un objectif est
propre à soi même et c'est pour ça c'est
ce qu'on disait leur moi aucun moment je
mets vraiment jamais l'accent sur les
jeux courtes et des dizaines de
kilomètres des dizaines des milliers de
mètres de dénivelé parce qu'on s'en fout
au final parce que ça c'est mon objectif
qui à moi mais c'est très très puissant
c'est pour une personne qui n'a jamais
jamais fait de sport on va reprendre
l'exemple de la course et qui se donne
un objectif dans trois mois d'aller
courir en 5 km c'est un objectif
faramineux pour lui tu vois et puis
c'est bien plus impressionnant ce que
quelqu'un qui devient fort me fait mal
at on fait je sais qu'ils essaient d'en
trouver mais ce qui a vraiment des
excuses moi j'ai vu j'écoute des
podcasts il ya un français là qui est
qui et qui
amputé des deux bras des deux jambes qui
a traversé la manche en nageant là mon
petit frère aussi il a perdu sa jambe
mais continue à faire du sport j'ai géré
sa manche aller voir une petite fille
sarah lou qui a malheureusement eu enfin
récemment un cancer très grave et mais
elle continue tu voyais cccc tragique
c'est tragique les handicapés les
maladies qu'on peut avoir mais tu peux
tu adapté à ce que à ce ce que tu as
dans un objectif qui est ambitieux pour
toi qui peut être tout simplement bet.e
déplacer juste de trois mètres autour de
la table quoi
quelque chose que je t'ai déjà entendu
je me suis vraiment reconnu là dedans
qui peut aussi apaiser la conscience de
quelqu'un qui a envie de débuter tue moi
je vois jamais courir avec des gens
puissent eux mêmes avant qu avant
d'entendre dire ce super castres encore
de grands décors de jean paul gaultier
moi je vais jamais couru avec des gens
que les foi parce que je les fais j'ai
toujours regretté parce que je coure
trop vite quand claude déjean puis quand
j'étais seul je capable de vraiment
mettre landes fait l'un pour beaumont
mon père mais ton l'intimé vraiment lent
puis de pommes sentir coupables de pas
accéléré de progresser puis quand tu
veux l'un s'ils le font c'est vraiment
le fun c'est de pas de porte donne et
d'efforts de jeu secourir bouger est en
mobilité faire lever des pulsations
cardiaques un petit peu mais à être
l'affiché que toi ce quelque chose tu
disais aussi sur le package en fait
voter c'est on s'entend le téton coureur
professionnel puis les groupes de
coursan morial court trop vite pour toi
c'est très puissant ce que tu dis c'est
très très important aussi je suis sûr
que tu que tu t'en ailles la
t on est aussi une société de
performance et dans tout domaine est
aujourd'hui la relation qu'on peut avoir
aux sports est liée à la performance en
tout cas ce que le grand public peut
avoir et j'ai l'impression que la course
la course à pied c'est le bel'zik ctu
par une heure courir je n'ai pas
pourquoi cette date environ une heure
courir et pendant une heure c'est
c'est ça une séance de course pour reçu
pour quelqu'un qui connaît pas le sport
mais en fait non c'est pas ça s'est
passé avant toi je pense que tu as un
petit peu plus aussi deux connaissent un
bagage de sport de sportifs de
connaissances qui fait qu'il ya aussi un
intérêt de développement de performance
allant de membres mais dans une optique
de simplement se tenir en santé on n'a
pas besoin de de s'arracher une heure
c'est c'est énorme une heure de course à
pied quand on a eu une vie qui était pas
de coureurs dans le passé c'est énorme
en termes de charge tissulaire sur le
corps c'est monstrueux c'est sûr que tu
vas te blesser au final qui aura tout
perdu parce que ça va être trop dur
mentalement ça va être trop dur
physiquement tu vas te faire mal et tu
vas pas y retourner donc c'est ça et
courir lentement effectivement c'est le
fun parce que quand t'es pas essoufflé
tu arrives à te connecter à tout
environnement 2 parce que tu vas voir
quinté quinté péter tapote ce 14 août
pour meurtre lorsque tu vois un max
magnifiques paysages mais il est fade
les nouvelles membres fat d'une dent
future gare de rien ce que tu écoutes au
site us hanafin tu t'étais ailleurs la
tête juste en train de survivre tandis
que quand tu vas plus tranquillement
tiens
nouveau restaurant par see you le mont
royal ces jolis seins raccoon puis tu
écoutes des podcasts écoutent de la
musique péter vraiment voilà tu te rends
dans une dimension qui est beaucoup plus
confortable et qui fait que au final tu
es mieux de faire tous les jours 10
minutes qu'une fois le sound iron là une
heure
ponctuellement
et c'est sûr que c'est paradoxal pour un
athlète de haut niveau de se dire mais
je vais pas courir avec vous parce que
vous courrez trop vite et ils rigolent
les gens jeudi dans le podcast jean
philippe wauthier mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai ce n'est pas une blague c'est que
mon plus gros vous faut que je fasse des
gros volume d'entraînement hebdomadaire
et si je fais ces gros volumes dans ce
une heure de
bain je vais avoir une fatigue
neurologiques je vais avoir une fatigue
physique venant c'est pas bien et donc
le gros volume que le fasse dans une
zone ultra confortable pour moi et cette
zone ultra confortable pour moi est trop
lente par rapport à mes amis avec qui je
vais courir parce qu ils sont toujours
dans cette zone qui est la zone
classique de la performance penser une
question d'ego tout ça aussi pas tout à
fait une question d'ego et puis tu
acceptes pas de dial et enfin de courir
à une vitesse qui est plus lente que si
tu marchais vite ou te faire doubler par
par une personne âgée ou voilà tu
utilises non c'est on a tous des ego qui
font que
même dans le sport on n'arrive pas être
assez doux avec soi-même pour accepter
le fait d'aller tout simplement courir
doucement puis les gens aussi qui
commence c'est arnaud celui qui parlait
de ce lieu comment ces accords est aussi
un humoriste québécois puis
lui il n'y avait pas compris la
différence entre jogging courir fait que
lui pensait que courir maintenant aller
courir 1 5 km celi genoux aux grandes
foulées dal ont offert ce l'était l'est
du pays des mauges je courais je voulais
je voulais courir à 5 kilomètres après 2
km j'avais envie de vomir c'est comment
est ce parce que le discours du jackpot
cours le type courait cette offre c'est
vraiment aussi une différence il ya
beaucoup de monde qui m'écrivent en
faisant georges je fais cinq minutes
puis j'ai envie de vomir s'est passé
quand on sait clairement que tu vas
trophy c'est sûr c'est sa forme le corps
n'aime pas non plus trop de répétitions
et puis je pense que vous connaissez
dans la natation les syndromes de
l'épaule fait nos douleurs tout sa
course même chose si tu réussis
finalement 1 par rapport au fait que tu
vas jeong et courir à avoir cette
connexion ou ça c'est fait mais je pense
à paris la natation du changement en
angle d'un millimètre qui va venir il
parle différemment mais en course à pied
pareil tu vas changer un petit peu
langue à laquelle ton pied va frapper le
sol mais au niveau de la charge
tissulaire sous le choc tout ce qui va
remonter de la cheville jusque jusqu'à
ton cou mais en changeant une petite
affaire de comment tu vas placer des
mains des pieds mais tu va répartir la
charge et le stimuli ce qui fait que tu
vas tu va progresser plus il a une
jeunesse dans tous les sports et il n'ya
pas one by one technique dans la course
même si encore une fois pour quelqu'un
qui connaît pas ça ça parait d'être un
truc très banal de courir très bête et
puis moi j'étais le premier à penser ça
au début mais c'est beaucoup plus
technique et complexe qu'est ce qu'on
peut qu'est-ce qu'on peut l'imaginer si
on veut faire les choses correctement
sans se faire mal et puis que ce soit ça
soit durable quoi
te lancer cette semaine autant annoncer
en fait un projet qui est peut-être ton
podcast dans mon bain talent antisec le
premier épisode dans le fond
corrigez moi si je me trompe pas car
tout ce que tu vois un peu behind de
synth de ce que les gens peuvent voir si
suivre ta carrière ton premier épisode
je l'écouté sur mon job avant hier
ou est-ce que tu nous amènes avec toi
derrière l' aventure d'ultra trail cape
town puits d'où t'est venue l'idée puis
qu'est ce que tu souhaites en renfort de
ce podcast mais j'en ai déjà répondu au
tout début de notre échange était en
parler de pourquoi tu partages pas tout
ça c'est aussi une question de temps et
moi je joue je suis j'aime beaucoup mon
entourage c'est familial amical mais la
communauté aussi des inconnus fin tu le
sais aussi sur les réseaux - je reçois
des messages de fin que ça me ça mais ça
me booste d'une force quelqu'un me dit
merci en ayant bu ça moi aussi bas me la
ccl voilà mais je veux je veux
ils me donnent tellement d'énergie que
moi je veux le rendre aussi et puis
j'aimerais en donner plus mais il ya une
question de temps aussi et ça a été une
grosse réflexion sur mon pourquoi si on
en parlait tout à l'heure mais en 2021
j'ai été sollicité beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de questions et comment si et
comment ça et comment tu manges et
comment tu dors et la nana na na na hey
les athlètes de haut niveau c'est des
machines c'est des extraterrestres mais
voilà bon bref grosse réflexion et j'ai
dit je me suis dit mais comment je peux
partager plus d'une manière qui va pas
me prendre trop d'énergie backs le
l'objectif des backstage vraiment le
inside tout ça et et de fil en aiguille
ben le podcast a été le pour moi le
canal le plus simple qui allait me
prendre plus énergique le moins
d'énergie qui allait montrer le plus de
cet envers du décor après je suis parti
tout seul je suis allé avec des experts
du domaine moi j'ai j'y connais je fais
juste à rose hill le truc mais l'idée
l'idée c'est ça en fait c'est vraiment
si je trouve que c'est très très
original de d'humaniser d'humains
d'humaniser le sport de haut niveau et
parce que je pense que ce que je vis
tous les jours c'est qui qui s'est
résumée à l'ag c'est une petit problème
qu'ils envoient la aucunement d'un super
héros
voilà et je pense que c'est la même
chose dans tous les sports et j'ai envie
de partager ça en toute spontanéité et
puis je stage à rien du tout là je vais
aller tout à l'heure à mon entraînement
de trac je vais allumer le micro et puis
je vais écouter le coach qui va dire je
vais on va enregistrer les échanges que
j'ai avec voilà et puis voilà c'est ça
l'idée c'est de partager plus l'envers
du décor pour répondre à toutes ces
questions auxquelles je n'ai pas pu
répondre depuis deux trois ans et que je
suis frustré de ne pas le faire parce
que je n'ai pas le temps et j'espère la
g1 peut synthétiser toutes ces questions
qui me reviennent tenter d'y répondre à
travers ce podcast alors laquelle limité
on l'a assez ciblé puisqu'il devrait
prendre fin à l'utmb 2022 au moins c'est
du concret tu vois ça nous donne une
feuille de route et un fil conducteur
c'est c'est c'est une recette voilà peu
importe qu'elle soit douce pour moi ma
recette je me fixe un objectif dans le
temps ok hyper ambitieux pour moi qui ai
lu tmb 2022 fin août c'est comme si tu
te fixer un objectif entreprenariale ce
que tu veux et puis quel cheminement je
vais avoir dans ma vie à tous les jours
pour tenter d'aller atteindre 7 réussir
cet objectif à la hauteur que je me suis
fixé et voilà ça c'est basique c'est
encore une histoire de courage très
banale mais qui sera peut-être fort de
sens en termes d'illustration de valeurs
de vie donc c'est tout nouveau sa part
on va essayer de faire deux épisodes par
mois prochain épisode c'est sais je peux
l'utiliser c'est l'importance dans une
année où tu es très voilà où tu es très
passionné par quelque chose d'avoir une
coupure très forte très marqué voilà
donc je parle de du québec de pourquoi
je passe l'hiver ici des activités qu'on
peut faire de pourquoi faut couper la
mêlée la baratte est dans le corps tout
ça donc c'est un peu training hivernale
hiver parler de ski de fond demain donc
c'est très commode que j'ai vraiment
aimé sur les gens qui nous écoutent
évidemment c'est des gens qui aiment les
podcasts lorsqu'ils sont rendus rendu à
1h40 de bois de castres mais je vous
invite à aller écouter ce soft c'est un
pilote le premier on l'a fait vraiment
pour moi c'est dans le langage qu est ce
qu ils appellent ça le pilote les
garages les gars qui monte salami moins
pour moi c'est un brouillon suis pas
très fier parce que voilà on l'a fait un
peu comme ça un peu d'animaux mans la
course en afrique du sud mais nous
fallait il nous fallait quelque chose si
on voulait démarrer quelque chose
présenter quelque chose on essayait puis
maintenant c'est sûr que la société qui
produit ça c'est des professionnels
c'est leur métier vous savez ce que
c'est il va falloir les rémunérés pour
qu'il fasse le montage de mes trucs donc
grâce à ce pilote on espère trouver le
partenaire qui va bien pour pouvoir
financer le financer le projet
je veux avoir j'ai deux dernières
questions
avant avant de te laisser aller la
première s'est joué à voir ta reste de
purée de patates douces s'il vous plaît
en fait la recette c'est pas moi qu'il
laissait c'est ma campagne mais les
ingrédients je peux les données mais là
ça a été ça a mis plusieurs années à
régler fm plusieurs courses à régler le
dosage parce qu'il ya des aliments qui
sont très forts en goût mais en gros
c'est de la patate douce c'est de la
carotte c'est de la betterave c'est du
gingembre c'est du curcuma est un peu de
sel voilà maintenant c'est juste trouver
le juste dosage pour pas que ça soit
trop fort en jambes rouen curcuma et
puis saingou qui déjà d'un point de vue
macro nutritionnelle micronutritionnel
c'est parfaite à tous là dedans première
chose vitamines électrolytes donc ça ce
premier objectif rempli deuxième en
termes de en termes de texture
quand tu es sur un effort de 30 durant
ce type capable donc ça savall sans
mâcher c'est facile à avaler la texture
je sais pas ça glisse tout seul est
troisième c'est en terme de goût aussi
m'en donner et canteloup à la casse est
trop prononcé sur le sucre ou le seul tu
es plus capable et lui laisse un goût
qui est assez neutre je dirais pour pas
trop te voilà donc
encore une fois on cherche cette pilule
miracle il va nous faire courir plus
vite nous faire enlever les douleurs ne
faire booster mais en fait c'est une
purée
et puis et puis voilà c'est ça et je
suis content parce que je suis je suis
ça fait longtemps que je j'ai mes amis
de la petite entreprise de nutrition nac
montréalaise que j'adore et ils sont
sympas parce qu'on s'est dit ok on va
essayer de faire une purée un peu
inspiré de ce temps cela va durer mais
qu'on puisse avoir avec nous dans une
petite poche comme projeté qu'il aimait
manger là et et c'est assez nouveau dans
le sport en puissance avec toi n'ont pas
exactement parce que c'est sûr que c'est
pas facile des fois quand tu es dans une
course où était dans une chambre d'hôtel
où t'as pas de quoi
faire cuire et tout ça donc ce serait
bien de pouvoir embarquer avec soi donc
voilà peut-être qu'on espère un fin de
l'année à voir un prototype de cinq ans
que sa mère qu'avec tous les mois c'est
sûr que c'est ce que j'utiliserai parce
que parce que si c'est parfait quoi très
très cause
en fait le jeune un prétendu porte son
objectif principal en ce moment c'est
vraiment le mont-blanc 2022
est ce que d'autres projets aussi
d'aventuré fait que ce cayenne ariana
qui démarre dans un mois et je te dirais
que ça fait deux mois que je dors plus
déjà cogné sa
caisse
non parce que je vais l'annoncer bientôt
mais c'est parce que je le dis donc
envie ni une simple j'aime pas trop non
c'est l'épreuve avance parce qu'après
tout d'un coup j'ai une pression à la
diversité de communautés qui est contre
productif pour moi je sais que la
question est ce qu'était ce qu'ils
étaient prêts à une question de son
identité
c'est la pire c'est que je dis c'est la
pierre c'est vrai c'est angoissante
parce que tu sais pas korben quand tu
vas sur un objectif ambitieux tu peux
pas être prêt maintenant c'est pas
ambitieux d'accord et donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai pas annoncé mais en gros
j'ai un objet un projet à plus long mais
il ya plein de raisons tellement de
raisons je suis passionné par la culture
autochtone hockey les i nous c'est
quelque chose qui me vous avez dû
comprendre je suis passionné par la
nature et puis des communautés qui
fonctionne avec la nature dans la nature
et puis voilà c'est pour moi c'est très
puissant je suis passionné par le québec
passionné par les aventures je suis pas
ce débat est passionné par les moins 35
voilà et j'aime projet pas donné par
l'océan aussi donc voilà l'histoire ce
passionné par l'océan si je suis
plongeurs sous-marins apnéistes c'est ma
vie des poissons et par la montagne au
sipi mon coeur balance entre les deux et
j'essaye à travers un projet peut-être
un peu artistique ou de vie de connecter
les deux éléments et ça sera
probablement à travers un projet plus
artiste artistique de films un peu comme
une sortie de lola darwin d'un poisson
qui sort de l'eau même pas en accéléré
que d'un coup il ya des pâtes et puis il
peut marcher dans sur terre mais ces
deux souvent quand je vais à des courses
la montagne très proche de l'eau pour ne
pas dire directement de tourner dans
l'eau et l'idée serait de voilà d'être
sous l'eau dans une interaction un petit
peu
naturel en apnée et pieds nus en train
de grimper tu as des montagnes sous
louer quand c'est très clair là tu peux
voilà et sortir de l'eau puis commence à
monter la montagne jusqu'au sommet et de
plus en plus profond et de plus en plus
haut
en montagne et jusqu'à une certaine
montagne que j'ai en tête là qui a
encore un petit peu secrète mais qui me
demandera d'avoir des compétences en
expédition polaire et un alpinisme que
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui et puis c'est un
domaine qui est très complexe et montrer
dangereux enfin pas dangereux mais une
gestion du risque et il est temps que je
commence à apprendre ça donc ça c'est
une raison aux cimes une autre raison
assez banal c'est que j'ai rencontré un
aventurier de métier là une sorte de
mike horn mais plus jeunes qui s'appelle
lourd il a acquis un très bon copain
quitte avec mon marathon des sables
on avait trop trop chaud il n'en pouvait
plus la banalité c'est 10 juillet 10 à
luri si je vais jouer à montréal steve r
vieille ans fait une petite aventure
polaire parce qu'il a une expertise là
dedans et
que tout ça fait que on a comparé à fin
février faire une expé polaire au nord
du québec
voilà donc tirer une poule k par moins
de 40 pendant une quinzaine de jours mon
voilà et c'est encore une fois comme
confiné ça va être le fil conducteur de
l'histoire une aventure de dépassement
de soi physiques extrêmes mais avec
autour des connexions qui vont se faire
avec le territoire local c'est un
territoire innu c'est là on va aller aux
réserves réservoir manicouagan du québec
la météorite qui frappe et là c'est la
5ème réserve mondiale de l'unesco il ya
énormément de recherches scientifiques
qui fait là il ya un patrimoine ya une
culture et des activités écotouristiques
il ya il ya une diversité est une
richesse locale alors qu'on peut se dire
le blanc-seing désert mais non c'est
très très très puissant et à travers
cette histoire on veut aller raconter ça
ça se passe dans un mois ça va être très
grosse après une grosse ampleur avec les
joueurs que dans le projet là et voilà
je commence à ne pas dormir la nuit donc
c'est mon indicateur que c'est le
célèbre jeu c'est le bon projet et si
vous me posez la question est-ce que je
m'entraîne quoi je vais juste me traîner
un petit peu physiquement ça fait partie
de ma vie mais j'ai volontairement
décidé de ne rien apprendre sur le pôle
erp à ce qui a énormément de livres et
déjà deux vidéos qui sont un petit peu
explicative de comment monter ta tente
avec des moufles par -40 comment je veux
volontairement ne rien savoir pour que
les images qu'on va ressortir que ce
soit c'est comme si toi tu connais rien
pour la qu'ils disent mais je sais si
j'avais été à sa place je
j'aurais tf1 de saboter la même chose tu
vois je veux vivre la la la la
découverte du truc et puis comme comme
au cid il ya très longtemps en arrière
tu es sur les peuple innu ancestrale qui
se déplaçait du père de la mère qui
transmettait le savoir à ses enfants
mais loury c'est une histoire de partage
aussi va m'apprendre ça et puis voilà
c'est le projet puis il s'appelle je
crois c'est la première fois que je vais
le dire il s'appelle ou ap ap hunan qui
veut dire dans le blanc de l'oeil en
language in ou en anglais nous et donc
voilà le fil conducteur est d'aller
faire le tour au complet de l'oeil du
québec cette méthode météorite qui a
frappé le québec il ya 250 millions
d'années en arrière et qui fait une
périphérie d'environ 250 kilomètres donc
voilà
on va faire au mieux on va faire au
mieux pour partager un maximum jésus
avant pendant après mais là le
le truc c'est que c'est du pôle erp
vous vous habite à montréal tu sais
comme sur son cellulaire au bout de cinq
secondes micro atx les batteries et puis
on n'a pas pour recharger un petit
panneau solaire mais ça va très très
très complexe et un gros défi d'aller
chercher des images de ce truc a donc
travaillé fort en ce moment là dessus et
on espère que ça va être ça va être ça
va être grandiose incroyable mathieu
merci infiniment d'une part et d'avoir
pris ton son horaire chargé le gitan
vote direct longtemps traîné
merci éléments pourraient merci ça vaut
pour l'accueil puis j'ai découvert votre
podcast parce que c'est bon la culture
québécoise souhaite que j'aime beaucoup
et puis puis vous poser des questions
très pertinentes et vous avez des eaux
des intervenants qui waouh
rcc puissant là c'est vraiment des bravo
les gars je suis fier d'avoir eu aussi
des trains cette lignée de personnes
sont venues ici chez vous et ça me
ferait plaisir merci beaucoup
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
pataquès combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre i entre le pitch vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de la whey trois pièces par morlaàs
par mois et vous avez les podcasts en
avançant qu'ils appuient premier de
votre groupe d'amis à recruter les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tuer
le la dynamique entre les amis de tout
le temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance je rentre de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que laure
le podcast fini voulu nous en dire
davantage on fait des encore moins de
filtres à préchac podcast avec le on
vient de finir de tourner le podcast on
va en jaser on va toucher les nicole non
nicoli pleut maintenant comme un fils
travaille la place grave a détaillé le
mets en jason par la conversion convient
d'avoir mais ce si vous voulez avoir
accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pécule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous